Wir haben alles dafür getan, um diesen Tag zu erleben.
Das ist doch Wahnsinn! Und da ist gekommen dieser eine Moment, da ist alles an Drehgern! Irre!
Der Bundespräsident steht, die Kanzlerin, war ein hartes Stück Arbeit, da war mal so viel gegeben, wie noch nie, um das zu erreichen, was sie noch nie hatten, nämlich Ingress fürs iPhone.
Freuden drehen, Schmerzen drehen zwischendurch, vielleicht höchstens mal, aber das hat sich nachher alles ausgezahlt.
Aber ich glaube, die Arbeit hat begonnen vor zehn Jahren.
Wenn einem Mann meiner Klasse mal die Worte fehlen, dann muss was Komisches passiert sein.
Der hat irgendwie drei Demons entdeckt, den PCAP-Demon, den File-Relay-Demon oder Service, ich weiß nicht, ob es Demons sind, und noch den House-Arrest-Demon, sag ich jetzt mal. Und er meint, die machen halt Dinge, die nicht für den User sind, sondern eher gegen den User. Also das ist halt Backdoors für sonst wen wären, also nicht... Eventuell nicht mal für Apple, sondern für andere. Und Apple hat aber dann, weil sie die Sache wohl als dramatisch ansehen oder weil sie ihren Ruf retten wollen oder wie auch immer, haben sie halt gleich auch jetzt hier so ein Service-Document rausgegeben und haben, genau bei Heisessen, der ist ein ganz guter Artikel gerade dazu, haben gleich ein Support-Document rausgegeben, wo halt die drei Dinger erklärt werden, was sie so machen und warum, wofür die da sind und in welchen Situationen die dann zum Einsatz kommen könnten und in welchen nicht. Und aber bei diesem Heisertikel, da hat dieser Jonathan Z-Punkt, sag ich mal, dann auch schon darauf geantwortet, dass die halt Sachen machen, die ja doch unnötig wären, wenn das so wäre, wie Apple das beschreibt. Also er hält an seiner Feststellung fest, dass die zu viel können. Apple behauptet zum Beispiel, dass das mitzniffen würde nur gehen, wenn man halt sein Phone auch an den Rechner anschließt und dann da Trust des Computers kommt und so weiter und so fort. Oder dass halt iTunes per WLAN auch was machen könnte. Und er meinte, dass sollte dann halt eben dieser Service dann nicht über WLAN stattfinden können. Das wäre zu kritisch.
Also zumindest ist Apple in der Lage, auf Zuruf auch mal eine Erklärung zu liefern, was eigentlich diese Dienste eigentlich offiziell, theoretisch tun sollen. Unabhängig davon, ob jetzt da Fehler drin sind oder vielleicht tatsächlich hier hinter Türen. Aber was machen die denn eigentlich genau? Also Pickup, Demon, so?
Der kann halt mitsniffen zu jeder Zeit. Das ist halt der Packet Capture.
Ja, welche Packets sind denn hier gemeint?
Na, alle.
Also WLAN zum Beispiel. Also der Sniffer liefert dann über USB an den Rechner entsprechenden Packet Trace.
Ich weiß ja nicht, wer dann auf das Ding irgendwie zugreifen kann und wer das dann kriegt, keine Ahnung. Aber ein Packet Capture kann grundsätzlich erstmal alles mitsniffen an.
Hier heißt es zumindest im Dokument From an iOS Device to a Trusted Computer.
Ja, das ist das, wo Apple da meint, dass es nur geht, wenn man im Computer auch halt trust das Computer geklickt hat.
Genau, was es aber auch erst seit iOS 7 gibt, dieses Feature.
Wer weiß, seit wann es das PCab gibt, vielleicht auch erst seitdem.
Ich kann mich irgendwann erinnern, dass auch mal so als Announcement, als cooles, tolles Feature und so geresen zu haben.
Ich weiß, dass man nicht immer von OS X nach Windows mal wechselt zum Zocken und mein Telefon hängt gerade dran, dann kommt auch immer trust das Computer, ich immer No. Man kann leider nicht sagen, merkt ihr den Scheiß, ich will das nicht jedes Mal beantworten, aber das geht auch irgendwie nicht.
Und dieses House Arrest, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, ist quasi diese Funktionalität, wo man in iTunes von bestimmten Programmen die Dokumente hin und her schieben kann, womit man dann quasi über iTunes da so ein Dokumentsync machen kann, auf so einem niedrigen Level zumindest.
Ja, aber der Jonathan Sidiasky meint, dass man damit halt alles mögliche hin und her schieben kann. Also das ist nur Apples Erklärung, was Apple damit tut, aber es geht wohl noch viel mehr. Also der meint, dass... Also man kann auf einen Dressbruch zugreifen und so.
Na ja, gut, aber ich meine, das ist jetzt so, wie wenn er sagt, dass auf dem iPhone jetzt irgendwas unter Ruh läuft und Apple hat irgendwie den Code dafür. Also ich meine, ja, natürlich, haben sie. Solange er das jetzt nicht belegen kann, dass sie das tatsächlich tun, ist es so ein bisschen so, hm.
Na ja, aber man muss sich schon noch fragen, warum da Sachen so ziemlich weit offen sind. Das heißt auch immer, sie könnten es jederzeit machen. Das ist schon nicht so schön. Also er hat schon recht, unten sagt er auch, was sie machen müssten und er sagt, sie sollen halt, er sagt ja gar nicht, macht das alles aus, das ist alles doof, sondern er sagt hier macht mal das, das und das. Also verharmlost die mal so ein bisschen und dass sie nur das können, was sie auch wirklich braucht. Das finde ich schon okay, das ist schon ein Ansatz.
Ja, er sagt, der Sniffer soll nicht über WLAN funktionieren, wobei mir jetzt nicht klar ist, ob er damit meint, dass er WLAN-Pakete snifft oder ob er über WLAN gesniffte Pakete mitteilt. Wahrscheinlich letztes.
Also, dass man den Dienst wahrscheinlich bei WLAN aktivieren kann von Remote.
Genau, dass man dann quasi über WLAN dann die ganzen Pakete abschnorren kann. Kann natürlich sein. Und was findet er noch falsch? Er findet falsch, dass dieses File-Relay die Backup-Verschlüsselung nicht respektiert?
Na, dass wenn ich Sachen halt, wenn ich meinen Backup verschlüssel, dann heißt es eigentlich, keiner soll an meine Daten ran. Und dann soll auch dieses File-Relay diese Daten halt nicht bekommen können. Aber dann macht man sich natürlich auch mit dem Support zu seinem iPhone begrenzt man sich ein. Aber das kann ja eigentlich auch wirklich meine Entscheidung sein, wenn die mir beim Support sagen, wir können leider ihr Telefon nicht gut supporten oder nicht gucken, was los ist, weil ist ja alles aus. Das ist ja dann eigentlich meine Entscheidung. So gesehen, können die da schon noch ein bisschen was machen und den Usern oder der Sicherheit der User ein bisschen entgegenkommen.
Also ich sag mal so, wenn in den nächsten zwei Wochen ein Update kommt für 6 und für 7.1, wo irgendwie das darauf Bezug nimmt, dann war es Apple wohl doch relativ wichtig. Und dann haben sie eingesehen, dass sie was falsch gemacht haben.
Diese Meldung kam relativ schnell, finde ich. Wann kam dieser Report? Der kam da erst vor ein paar Tagen, oder? Und schon, schwupp, hauen die da ein neues Support-Document raus. Ich meine, das Support-Document heißt jetzt erstmal noch nichts, außer dass sie ein bisschen rumlabern. Aber ich würde schon sagen, sie nehmen das ernst.
Naja, wenn wirklich wirklich was dran ist an dem, was Siedarski da schreibt, dann werden sie sicherlich auch ein Update machen. Also das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie da jetzt drauf sitzen bleiben.
Man weset ja nicht.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass er ihnen vorwirft, dass sie eine absichtliche Backdoor eingebaut haben.
Naja, doch schon ein bisschen, oder?
Ja gut, der eigentliche Vorwurf ist ja, da ist was drin, das von der NSA benutzt werden kann oder anderen dritten Diensten.
Ja gut, aber der Vorwurf, den kannst du ja in die Variante, die waren da zu schlampig und die sollen mal mit ihrer Security klarkommen, aufteilen. Oder die haben das da absichtlich reingemacht, damit man das dann auch benutzen kann, wenn man Law Enforcement ist. Und das sind ja zwei unterschiedliche Dinge.
Naja, also wir nehmen das zur Kenntnis, dass da was, was theoretisch vielleicht unter Umständen ein Problem sein könnte, unter bestimmten Umständen.
Es bestand zu keinem Zeitpunkt eine Gefahr für die Bevölkerung.
Wir evakuieren nur Vorsicht.
Keine Gefahr, aber halten sie Türen und Fenster geschlossen.
Im Chat wird das neue iTunes angemahnt. Will jemand Worte darüber verlieren oder schimpfen?
Alles anders, alles bunt. Man muss alles wieder finden.
Warte mal, welches neue iTunes ist jetzt gemeint?
Das mit dem roten Icon.
Ja, das ist noch gar nicht drin.
Doch. Auf Yosemite gibt es es als Beta.
Ich habe das noch nicht ausprobiert.
Ich sage mal so, wer das Design von Yosemite bisher nicht mochte, wird auch das neue iTunes nicht mögen und zwar gar nicht. Ansonsten ist es halt iTunes. Ich meine, das war vorher schon nicht gut. Und es ist nicht wirklich besser geworden.
Was ich echt richtig schlecht finde, muss ich mal sagen, ist halt diese Abtrennung zu den anderen Fenstern. Du siehst gar nicht mal, wo das Programm da aufhört, wenn das über anderen Fenstern liegt.
Die Schatten sind zu klein?
Also da oben, oder irgendwie dieser Kontrast, wie ist denn das hier, das ist doch irgendwie alles... Also da ist das klarer. Das geht halt so nahtlos ineinander über, weil da kein Verlauf mehr drauf ist und die Kontrastkanten halt irgendwie fehlen. Und ich finde das irgendwie doch so ein bisschen lasch vom Design her.
Ja gut, das ist jetzt aber auch nicht unbedingt ein Problem von iTunes, wenn du dir anguckst, wie Safari das macht.
Also ich als Konneceur, als Ästhet, kann damit nicht mehr anfinden.
Also sagen wir mal so, beim bisherigen iTunes konnte man wenigstens diese Seitenleiste noch wieder anmachen und das haben sie jetzt ausgebaut zu haben.
Ich mach mein iTunes komplett so... Hier, wir wissen schon... Ich hab auch hier noch diesen...
Aber ich muss sagen, über iTunes zu schimpfen, das hat meiner Meinung nach nicht so richtig viel Sinn.
Das haben wir oft genug gemacht. Tim schlägt auch schon gleich einen dabei.
Also das ist irgendwie so... Vor allen Dingen, wie heißt es so schön, wenn jemand auf dem Boden liegt, soll man nicht noch nachtreten. Also das trifft auch...
Du, das iTunes ist so flach! Da ist gar nichts mehr zum Flattrampeln.
Na ja, immerhin Füße abwischen. Dennis, Bitcoin 51%, du wolltest uns erklären, was es damit auf sich hat.
Moment, erstmal muss ich Tim fragen, sind das deine Bitcoins da oben in deiner Menüleister?
Das ist der Bitcoin-Preis.
Kurz jetzt, 51%?
Ja, und zwar die Sache ist, dass es gab einen Pool, der hatte mehr als 51% Miningpower, das heißt, der hat mehr als 51 aller Bitcoins erstellt, also pro Tag heißt es jetzt immer, was gerade so aktuell erstellt wird. Und das wird schon seit Jahren gesagt, dass das halt nicht so sein soll. Der Grund ist, dass wenn man halt in der Hand hat, welche Blöcke halt an die Blockchain rangehangen werden, dann kann man damit böse Dinge tun. Ihr müsst euch vorstellen, ich bin der Poolbetreiber, hab, sagen wir mal, die mehr als 50% oder 60% oder so. Und da ist gerade die Blockchain und ein anderer Pool findet einen Block, dann könnte ich den einfach ignorieren und könnte weiter selber rechnen und meinen Block an die Blockchain hängen, dann sind immer noch beide gleich groß, da ich aber mehr Mining-Power habe, ist die Chance, dass ich den nächsten Block finde, ist ja um 10% höher, als dass die anderen den nächsten Block finden. Und dadurch kann ich immer meine, meinen Pfad der Blöcke sozusagen erweitern und die anderen einfach weg ignorieren. Und in dem Augenblick, wo ich das kann, kann ich halt auch die Ausgaben, die andere machen und die schon in einem validen Block gefunden wurden, kann ich dann in meinen Blöcken wieder rückgängig machen oder ich kann halt alles Mögliche damit machen, weil...
Schindluder betreiben.
Ja, und das ist das Problem so ganz simpel. Wenn ihr genaue Fragen habt, dann müsst ihr jetzt raushauen. Das war die Kurzfassung, so grob.
Gibt es denn Hinweise darauf, dass das passiert?
Nö.
Also ist denn das auch immer noch so, dass dieser eine Verbund 51% der Power hat?
Nee, das ist diese, die haben jetzt, das war ja jetzt schon zwei, drei Wochen her, wo das eigentlich war. Und diese Giga, also ghash.io heißt der Pool, die haben sich mit der Bitcoin Foundation an den Tisch gesetzt und haben gesagt, immer wenn sie jetzt mehr als, oder sagen wir mal andersrum, immer wenn sie 40% oder mehr an Mining-Power haben, dann rufen sie ihre User dazu auf, den Pool zu wechseln. Also sie sorgen jetzt freiwillig dafür, dass sie nicht mehr über 40% haben. Weil eigentlich bei 40% ist das Problem schon sehr hoch.
Das heißt, die beschränken sich quasi selber?
Die beschränken sich selber, genau, damit sie diese Macht nicht bekommen. Ist eigentlich ein bisschen bekloppt, weil das Problem ist eigentlich weiterhin vorhanden, nur ein bisschen unterschwelliger. Stell dir vor, Typ A hat einen Pool mit 25% und Typ B hat einen Pool mit 25%. Der eine ist in Australien, der andere ist in Europa und alle denken ja, die kennen sich ja gar nicht, aber in Wirklichkeit sind das die dicksten Buddies. Die tun sich zusammen und dann können sie natürlich genau den gleichen Trick machen, weil sie können zusammen halt bestimmen, welcher Block als nächstes an die Blockchain kommt und können einfach die anderen so ein bisschen weg ignorieren und wenn du mehr Mining-Power hast, dann hast du halt immer diesen kleinen prozentualen Vorteil und ja, dadurch kann man halt schummeln. Wer? Der jetzige, diese Giga-Hash-IO? Na ja, anscheinend nicht, aber es könnte halt passieren. Es kann ja auch sein, dass jemand deren Server hackt und das dann ausnutzt oder irgendwie so, jedenfalls so rein aus Wohlfühlgründen sollte kein Pool mehr als diese 40 oder ja.
Ich meine, die haben ja kein Interesse daran, dass jetzt da die nächste Druckwelle nach unten den Kurs drückt auch, wenn dann alle, oh mein Gott.
Ja, es hat auch einer, hab ich glaube ich hier in der Sendung schon mal gehabt, oder dass einer meinte, dass jemand, der so einen Pool hat, ja der verdient ja am Tag irgendwie, lass ihn einen Prozent dieser Bitcoins, also an Donations oder an Fees, der irgendwie einkassieren, am Tag werden 144 Blöcke gefunden, mal 25 Bitcoins, das sind 3600 Bitcoins am Tag, ein Prozent davon sind 36. Wenn du jetzt bei 50 Prozent der Mining-Power bist, dann bist du mal noch bei 18 Bitcoins am Tag, die so einen Pool verdienen, da kannst du dir ausrechnen, was die an Geld machen. Das aufs Spiel zu setzen, indem sie da so ein bisschen Double-Spending-Spiele reinmachen, ich weiß nicht, ob sich das lohnt. Klar, da gehen auch manchmal riesengroße Transactions mit Tausenden von Bitcoins durch die Gegend, die man manipulieren könnte. Aber ich denke, jeden Tag saubere 18 Bitcoins verdienen ist viel cooler, als da die Großmanipulationen vorzunehmen.
Da ging mich nicht hängen, wehren, sag ich mal.
Und wenn die dabei erwischt werden, ist ja ihr Pool am Arsch, dann geht ja da keiner mehr hin.
Und was hat den Pool so groß gemacht?
Ich glaube, das war auch so ein, ich bin mir aber nicht so sicher, ich glaube, das war so ein Unternehmen, Unternehmen, die halt Mining-Power verkaufen, wo du halt keine Hardware haben musst, sondern du kaufst einfach bei denen Power ein, die bestellen die Hardware oder irgendwie so. Die vermieten dir sozusagen Bitcoin-Hardware und du meinst dafür dann bei denen. Verstehe, aber ich bin mir aber jetzt nicht so sicher, hab mir das Ding nie angeguckt.
Ich dachte, Teil des Pool-Signs bedeutet auch, da die Gewinne zu teilen.
Na ja, also die Gewinne, die so ein Pool macht, die werden ja komplett an die User ausgeschüttet. So damit, aber der Pool, der muss ja, das hat ja einen Grund, warum alle irgendwie einen Pool machen. Du nimmst halt 1, 2, 3, 4 Prozent oder wie viel auch immer, die du halt abkassierst für deine ISP, für deine Arbeit, die du hast, für das Problem, wenn halt doch ein anderer Pool immer auch in der gleichen Zeit einen Block findet und dein Block, den du schon ausgezahlt hast, der für Invalid erklärt wurde, weil der andere doch irgendwie eine Sekunde schneller war als du, dann hast du halt bezahlt, ohne dass du halt irgendwie den entsprechenden Wert bekommen hast. Das nennt man halt einen Invalid-Block und für so eine Ausfälle musst du halt so ein bisschen Gebühren von deinem User nehmen, sonst überlebst du nicht, sonst musst du ja mehr auszahlen, als du irgendwie einkassierst. Und deswegen nimmt man halt so, ich glaube zum Beispiel BTC-Gild, die nehmen 5 Prozent oder DeepHash, nee, wie hieß der, DeepHash-DeepBit? Der hat damals für irgendwas, hat er glaube ich 11 Prozent genommen, was auch sehr eine riskante Sache war, wo halt man als Pool viel nehmen muss. Aber inzwischen sind die alle so bei, keine Ahnung, manche nehmen 0 Prozent, um User anzulocken und so weiter. Aber das können wir natürlich nicht auf lange Sicht machen, weil dann gehen die um ein Pleite.
Ich glaube im Chat meint auch jemand, dass gihash.io das auch tun würde.
Ja, aber die ganze Zeit, das kann nicht lange gut gehen, weil dann sind die irgendwann, Leute haben eine Menge probiert, aber oder das gab es welche, die 0 Prozent genommen haben, die haben dann halt irgendwie nach zwei, drei Wochen, nachdem genug Kohle da war, haben sie dann plötzlich irgendwie sich verabschiedet und waren weg. Also da muss man ein bisschen aufpassen. Wenn es zu billig ist, dann ist irgendwas faul.
Gab noch was anderes? Warte mal, da muss ich mal kurz in die Sendungsnotizen vom letzten Mal...
Die Taz nimmt jetzt Bitcoins.
Reinschauen.
Die Taz.
War es als Spende oder was? Oder auch um Abos zu...
Na, als Spende. Hab ich heute mal geguckt und die hatten schon 11 Bitcoins. Und da man ja über die Adresse bei Blockchain Info gucken kann, was da so los ist, hab ich mal so durchgescrollt und hab gesehen, dass ein Einziger hat den 10 Bitcoins rübergeschoben. Das heißt, im Großen und Ganzen haben die eigentlich erst einen Bitcoin eingenommen. Aber es ist auch erst seit heute oder gestern so gesehen. Mal gucken. Na, da ist es entweder richtig reich oder die wollten so tun als ob und haben sich das selbst überwiesen. Geht ja auch, weiß man ja immer nicht, ne? Aber es könnte doch sein, dass einer richtig fett Bitcoins hat und sich dachte, tats ist ja mal eine gute Sache. Die tote Baummedien. Sind derweil gerade 10 Bitcoins, sind 4.600 Euro oder so gerade. Also ist jetzt nicht so wenig, da kriegt er schon ein bisschen mehr als ein Jahresabbo, oder?
Auf jeden Fall. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie sich das so preislich so entwickelt hat bei der Tats, aber macht es nicht genau.
Ich kann ja mal schnell gucken hier, wo war das?
Hier ist der Artikel. Das ist das hier.
Und wenn man jetzt dort die Adresse nimmt und die bei Blockchain Info reinhängt, dann sieht das so hier aus.
Und zwar zack.
Dann kann man hier sehen, bei Blockchain Info, die sind jetzt bei 11,01 Bitcoins. Als ich geguckt hab, waren sie noch bei 10,98 oder so. Also da passiert noch ein bisschen was. Man kann ja auch hier immer 0,002, 0,01, 0,01, 0,002, 0,002, 0,008 und so weiter. Also denen rasseln jetzt halt da die Beträge rein. Sind sogar noch alle unbestätigt hier, weil die relativ frisch sind, die letzten fünf. Also da geht was. Und was gibt's noch an Bitcoins? Dell nimmt jetzt Bitcoins. Ich glaube, das war auch innerhalb der letzten zwei Wochen, oder? Ist jetzt auch nicht so eine kleine Nummer, schon eher ein größerer Onlineshop. Ja, was hatte noch Bitcoins genommen? Xperia hat oder Expedia hat mehr schon, dass die Bitcoins nehmen. Und mehr fällt mir da erstmal gerade nicht ein eigentlich.
Wie schon im Chat gerade gesagt, also wir nehmen auch alle Bitcoin. Also wenn euch Taz zu doof ist, oder ihr keinen Dell-Computer haben wollt, ihr bei Apple noch nicht eure Bitcoins loswerden wollt, Metaebene Tim, Dennis, Roddy und ich, wir nehmen auch alle Bitcoin.
Damit ihr sie nicht so weit schleppen musst. Ich hab noch eine andere Webseite neulich entdeckt, da wollte ich dich mal fragen, ob du die kennst, Dennis, und ob du das irgendwie übersetzen kannst. Die Webseite heißt fiatleak.com und die analysieren irgendwie die Bitcoin-Transaktionen und versuchen herauszufinden, wo gerade auf der Welt echtes Fiat-Geld in Bitcoin investiert wird. So deutlich das jetzt.
Das heißt, wenn das Geld in die Bitcoins fließt und nicht in die andere Richtung, dann müsste der Kurs eigentlich auch steigen, oder wie?
Ich weiß nicht, bin mir nicht so sicher, ob die hier nicht nur die eine einzige Seite visualisieren. Weil hier sind jetzt nur so Bitcoin-Verkäufe zu sehen. Also du kennst es nicht. Neulich ging ja mal der Kurs hoch und dann schaute ich da mal. Schön, dass die Karte auch immer anzeigt, wo gerade Tag und Nacht ist. Aber es rasselte so dermaßen viel Bitcoin gegen China auf dieser Karte. Das war schon wirklich bemerkenswert. Als ich damals draufschaute, wo China nicht Mitternacht hatte, da ratterte es da ganz schön rein.
Und das, obwohl es bei denen ja irgendwie nicht so gewollt ist und verboten wird, und handeln darf man mit auch nicht mehr und Banken auch nicht. Und eigentlich ist ja China so gut wie alles verboten mit Bitcoins, oder? Also offiziell irgendwie, du darfst keine Bitcoins nehmen und Banken dürfen auch nicht hier so mit Exchange und so, ist alles nicht mehr. Das einzige, was noch geht, ist zwischen Privatpersonen. Da machen sie wohl noch nichts oder weiß nicht so genau, wie da die Regeln sind. Aber das ist das Einzige, was dann noch offiziell ist. Also andere ist nicht mehr gewünscht.
Ja, also hier passiert auf jeden Fall eine ganze Menge auf dieser Karte.
Und das wird hier so hin und her geblubbert.
Ihr merkt schon, ihr dachtet wahrscheinlich am Anfang, dass mit dem Sommerloch das nur ein Spaß war. Wir leben das Sommerloch. Apropos Sommerloch, habe ich mal was Unterhaltsames, was ich so im Sommerloch mache. Und zwar spiele ich Minecraft wieder. Warum? Also ich habe früher schon mal Minecraft gespielt und dann irgendwann mal wieder sein lassen. Und letztens habe ich einen Kollegen getroffen, bei dem ich das Finale, das WM-Finale, geguckt habe. Und da war noch ein anderer Kollege. Und irgendwann sprachen wir über Spiele, über Spieldesign, über Indie-Spiele und dann über Minecraft. Und dann meinte der Kollege...
Weil das Finale so langweilig war.
Nee, nee, das war nicht an dem Tag. Meinte der Kollege irgendwie so, ja Minecraft, Minecraft, das ist doch dieses Bauspiel, das interessiert mich nicht so. Und dann meinte ich so, Lucas, du spielst jedes verdammte Indie-Spiel, was nicht bei drei auf den Bäumen ist. Und du spielst Minecraft nicht. Und dann musste man ihm erstmal erklären, dass Minecraft halt nicht nur so ein Aufbauspiel ist. Was dann daran endete, dass er... Kommt mal gleich zu. Dass er gesagt hat, okay, nach so einer Stunde von mir und dem anderen Kollegen einreden und erklären, was Minecraft ist, hat er dann gemeint so, okay, fuck it, es ist um 10.00 morgens, es ist zwar Montag, wir müssen arbeiten, aber ich kaufe mir jetzt Minecraft und wir spielen dann Beamer, jetzt so My First Minecraft-Session. Und ging natürlich bis um eins. Dann bin ich und der Kollege raus. Und ich meinte zum Kollegen, der geht jetzt bestimmt noch mal so kurz an den Rechner und denkt so, naja, so fünf Minuten spiel ich noch, ne? Frag ihn nächsten Morgen, bis um vier hat er gezockt. Dann hat er halt auch angefangen, als er das jetzt überhaupt mal so geschnallt hatte.
Die Arbeitszeiten sind von wann bis wann.
Er war früher im Büro, aber er sah ganz schön durch aus. Auf jeden Fall war er dann so begeistert, dass ich tatsächlich meinen alten Minecraft-Server wieder abgedatet hab und gesagt hab, wenn Schluckers hier so Singleplayer-Mode ist ja voll öde, lass mal zusammenzocken und jetzt spiel ich mit ihm und sogar noch zwei anderen.
Ich glaub, du hast Berlin Kreuzberg nachgebildet.
Und dabei ist mir auch erst mal wieder klar geworden, was für ein großartiges Spiel Minecraft eigentlich ist. Und ich hab so...
Also du und Dennis, ihr habt beide mal vor Äonen in Movamex Minecraft vorgestellt.
Ich nicht.
Doch.
Aber ihr habt das nie gespielt.
Du hast das nie gespielt.
Noch nie gespielt.
Das sollte noch sonst gewesen sein.
Stimmt's aber okay, hab ich mit dir Minecraft gezockt? Ich hab vielleicht mit davon erzählt, weil ich hab bei anderen im Club immer daneben gesessen. Im Club gibt's immer so Vans, Tower Defense, Minecraft. Und ich sitz dann immer daneben und hab's mir reingezogen. Aber selber hab ich's eigentlich nie gespielt.
Also gibt's schon noch mal Potenzial, dich für drei Monate aus der Gesellschaft zu verballern?
Da müsst du auch erklären, was da dran cool ist. Das ist ja nur so ein Aufbauspiel.
Das ist halt so echt die Misconception.
Jetzt der Elevator-Pitch. Also bei mir ist es ja besonders schwierig, weil ich ja... Also bis ich wirklich mal ein Spiel spiele, da muss ich schon ganz schön was rocken. Und so Sachen, die potenziell so lange dauern, da...
Also das Problem, das heißt lange dauern. Es gibt einfach immer was zu tun.
Erklär jetzt erstmal nochmal.
Okay, Minecraft 101. Also die Top-Level-Description würde sein, es ist ein Open-World-Sandbox-Game. Das heißt, in Sandbox, ich glaube, würde sich darauf beziehen, dass es halt Physik gibt und so bestimmte Regeln, aber die sehr vereinfacht sind. Also die reale Welt sehr vereinfacht darstellen und bestimmte Sachen halt, die in echt nicht gehen, da halt gehen. Zum Beispiel, wenn du irgendwie einen Tee in die Landschaft baust und du würdest den Stiel vom Tee wegmachen, dann würde das Querstück einfach in der Luft schweben. Also so vereinfachte Physik halt. Doch, da fallen auch Sachen runter, aber die meisten Sachen, die fallen nicht runter. Spieler fallen zum Beispiel runter. Oder bestimmte Sachen, wie zum Beispiel Sand, fällt runter. Egal, so. Und Open World heißt, ist halt komplett offen. Du kannst dich bewegen, wie du willst. Das ist nicht so wie bei anderen Simulationsspielen oder so, wo du halt immer in deinem Spiel-Regelkäfig bist. Zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt sowas wie SimCity oder so nimmst. Du kannst halt Häuser bauen und denkst so, ich hab ja alle Freiheiten, ich kann ja hier Häuser bauen und so. Aber es verfolgt halt bestimmte Regeln, bestimmte Abläufe und so weiter. Und in Minecraft gibt es das nicht, sondern das Spiel ist nur so spannend, wie dein Kopf es dir macht sozusagen. Also ein wahnsinnig unkreativer und allgemein langweiliger Mensch würde wahrscheinlich mit Minecraft keinen Spaß haben. Nerds zum Beispiel ist für dieses Spiel für Nerds extrem gefährlich. Extrem war es auch so ein Faktor. Die Reizpunkte von Minecraft, warum das großartig ist. Es ist erstens kein Aufbauspiel, weil der ursprüngliche Minecraft-Modus ist der sogenannte Survival Mode. Und der geht so.
Damit die Zombies die nachts rauskommen?
Genau, du wachst halt auf, du startest das Spiel, deine Welt wird generiert, jede Welt sieht auch anders aus. Wenn du an die Grenze deines Erfahrungshorizons läufst, den du gerade siehst, wird das nächste Stück Welt generiert und die kann unendlich groß werden. Größer als die Erdoberfläche im Prinzip. Also wirklich beliebig groß. Du wachst halt auf und siehst nur diese Blöcke. Und ein Block ist einmal einen Meter, so scale gedacht. Und dann hast du einen Grasblock und einen Baumblock oder einen Baumstammblock und noch einen oben drüber. Und dann die Blätter sind auch Blöcke. Alles sehr blockig, acht mit Pixel-Grafik. Und dann bist du in dieser Insel und weißt erst mal nichts zu tun. Hast du ein leeres Inventory unten drin, so ein paar Herzchen und so ein paar Fleischkeulen in deiner Status leistet? Die eine ist Hunger, die andere ist halt so dein Gesundheitszustand. Und dann läufst du da so rum und klickst natürlich, wie man das so macht, mit der linken Maustaste, mal mit der rechten Maustaste und guckst, was so geht. So First-Person-Perspektive, ne? Und dann stellst du fest, wenn du links gedrückt hältst, dann fängst du die Hand irgendwie an zu wackeln und wenn du das auf irgendwas drauf zeigst, dann irgendwann springt dich dieser Block an. Also wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel bei Gras oder so einen Sandblock einfach so draufhältst, dann macht der so und dann hast du diesen Block in deinem Inventory. Kannst du den auswählen und wieder hin platzieren. So weit, so gut. Und dann denkst du erstmal, ja okay, ist ja super. Und dann wird's plötzlich dunkel. Also alle 10 Minuten ist Tag und Nachtwechsel. Und so richtig mit Sonne geht im Osten auf und geht im Westen unter, ist das so, ja? So rum ist das. Und die Sterne wandern und so weiter, alles in 8-Bit-Pixel-Grafik. Und plötzlich, wenn es dunkel wird, hört man so ein und du siehst so ein paar leuchtende Augen in der Dunkelheit. Und wenn du nicht vorbereitet bist, wenn du dir nicht ein YouTube-Video angeguckt hast, stirbst du erstmal die erste Nacht direkt von irgendeiner Zombie-Attacke und du denkst dir, what the fuck, weil es ist dunkel, du siehst nichts, du hast kein Licht und du hörst nur diese Geräusche und plötzlich greifen dich irgendwelche Zombies an. Okay, du hast eine Response, es ist wieder Tag und jetzt denkst du dir, alles klar, also okay, es wird Nacht, die Zombies kommen. Was du dann machst, ist natürlich irgendwie, du buddelst dir ein Loch ins Gras und wenn es dunkel wird, machst du einfach die Erdblöcke über dich drüber und wartest, bis es wieder Tag wird. So, dann irgendwann stellst du fest, okay, guck mal da drüben im Stein, der Stein hat irgendwie so schwarze Punkte, hau ich mal drauf, oh, kommt Kohle raus. Dann kannst du den Baum kaputt hauen, dann kannst du den Baum zu Brettern machen, kombinierst du Brett und Kohle, kriegst du eine Fackel. Stellst dir die Fackeln auf und irgendwann merkst du, wie kombiniert man nochmal? Na, wenn du dein Inventory aufmachst, gibt es so eine 2x2-Area, wo du so Sachen reindropfen kannst und bestimmte Kombinationen ergeben dann so andere Gegenstände. Das ist der Crafting-Teil. Mine ist halt so rausbuddeln, Crafting ist so, kombiniere Holz mit Kohle, kriegst eine Fackel. Oder kombiniere Holz mit einer Reihe von Steinen, kriegst du eine Steinaxt. Also irgendwann checkst du, ah Moment, ich kann mir aus den Sachen, die ich hier so abbaue, kann ich mir Tools bauen, Torches bauen.
Wie viele verschiedene Tools gibt es inzwischen schon?
Ja, ich glaub...
Gibt es auch schon Diamanten und Wasser? Man kann ja binäre Schalter bauen bei Minecraft. Kennen wir ja schon von diesen Adirern und so.
Genau, jetzt geht es halt so weiter. Und dann baust du dir Fackeln, du merkst, die Zombies, die kommen nicht, wenn die Fackeln da stehen. Das heißt, du sicherst erst mal deine Basis, deine Homebase, erst mal mit Fackeln ab. Und das geile ist halt so dieses Gefühl, dass du dich vom Caveman erhebst, der vor Zombies Angst hat. Okay, so langsam kontrolliere ich hier mal die Lage und baue mir eine Base und baue mir ein Haus, wo die Zombies nicht reinkommen. Und nachts buddel ich einfach in die Tiefe und hole mir geile Rohstoffe aus der Erde. Und tagsüber baue ich draußen weiter. Das geht schon mal relativ schnell. Irgendwann findest du Eisen. Und irgendwann checkst du, okay, mit Eisen kann ich mir eine Rüstung bauen. Ich kann mir ein Schwert bauen. Und dann ist der nächste Evolutionsschritt in deinem Open-World-Erlebnis. Alles klar, ich erhebe mich nicht nur vom totalen Caveman zum Mittelalter, sondern jetzt werden die Zombies gejagt. Also jetzt hab ich nicht mehr Angst vor den Zombies, sondern das ist jetzt ein Ressourcenlieferant für mich. Was liefern die denn? Die droppen halt Rohstoffe für geile Crafting-Recipes, die es nur von den Zombies gibt. Die du nicht ausbuddeln kannst. Das heißt, irgendwann kommt so der Punkt, du willst jetzt den nächsten Crafting- und Bauschritt machen. Das heißt, zum Beispiel bestimmte Monster droppen Gunpowder. Das gibt es nur von den Monstern. Und mit denen kann man TNT machen. Ja, gibt es halt, sagen wir mal, Mops einfach. Oder Monster. Und mit dem Gunpowder mit Sand kombiniert gibt es TNT. Und da kann man natürlich auch ganz viel Spaß haben. Und irgendwann geht das dann weiter und du gehst in die Industrialisierung. Weil so die ganze Zeit rumrennen und das abbauen und kombinieren, das wird halt mühselig. Und es fangen an, die Leute halt automatisierte Farmen zu bauen.
Die automatisch bewässert werden.
Genau, automatisch bewässert werden. Oder Zombie fallen. Das heißt zum Beispiel ein Kaktus. Wenn du gegen einen Kaktus läufst, tut das halt weh. Was die Leute am Anfang gemacht haben. Die haben halt an Gruben gegraben, haben Kaktänen angepflanzt, sind dann nachts rumgelaufen, haben die Zombies in diese Grube gelockt. Die sind dann halt kaputt gegangen und haben sich unten so einen kleinen Gully gebaut, wo dann die ganzen gedroppten Items einfach durchfallen. Und sind dann so ganz entspannt am Seiten gangen, die Grube runter und haben dann unten einfach nur noch die Items geholt. Und irgendwann fingen die halt an so mit Lava. Also es gibt Lava und es gibt Wasser. Dann haben die Fallen gebaut, wo an der einen Seite Wasser rauskommt. Das hat dann die Zombies sozusagen weggespült an den Rand. Und am Rand war Lava. Und dann sind die halt so immer, die konnten halt der Strömung nicht widerstehen und wurden dann automatisch irgendwo eingesammelt von der Strömung gegen die Lava gedrückt, gekillt, Loot wieder durch den Gulli und so weiter. Und dann fangen die Leute an halt, fängst du halt an auf deine Nahrungsversorgung. Also wenn deine Health Points runtergehen, das Einzige, wie du das wieder herstellen kannst, ist, indem du was isst. Dann kannst du halt rumgehen und irgendwelche Tiere killen. Ja, zum Beispiel eine Kuh würde so einen Fleischlappen droppen. Wenn du den so isst, kriegste zwei Health Points. Wenn du das in den Ofen steckst, kriegste fünf. Ja, und dann, also du musst einen Ofen bauen, steckst du das Raw Beef rein, kriegst du ein Cooked Beef hinten raus, mit mehr Health Points und so weiter. Das heißt, irgendwann musst du deine Nahrungskette stabilisieren, ja, in deiner Basis. Das heißt, du fängst an Weizen anzubauen, einen Kuhstall zu halten, solches Zeug. Und es geht halt immer so weiter. Das Gefühl von Progress ist halt einfach wahnsinnig stark, das ganze Spiel über. Und mit jedem Schritt, den du sozusagen weiter machst und vorwärts kommst da, desto mehr Bock hast du, noch größere Sachen zu bauen. Und jetzt kommt halt das Krasse noch dazu, was wir eben auch schon ein paar Mal besprochen hatten. Es gibt halt elektrische Schaltungen auch da drin. Also du kannst Redstone, heißt das Material, das ist so ein Pulver, und wenn man das in einer Spur legt, dann gehen da sozusagen elektrische Signale durch. Und das ist auch das Video. Du weißt ja damals die 16-Bit-Alu-Unit, die jemand in Minecraft gebaut hat. Kannst du dich erinnern? Genau das. Und das benutzen die Leute jetzt für alles mögliche. Die gehen sowas von ab. Und dieser Typ, der das gebaut hat, der hat so viele Sachen eingebaut. Es gibt jetzt Repeater, es gibt Comparatoren, und damit bauen die Leute halt die Logic Gates und Uhren. Also dieses Redstone, da gibt es halt so eine Physik dahinter. Also das Spiel hat so eine Game Loop, und der Tick kommt, jede hundertstel Sekunde oder irgendwie sowas, ist ein Game Loop-Tick sozusagen. Und das Redstone haben sie halt gemessen dann irgendwann. Die Leute, ah ja, das sind so und so viele Ticks, braucht es, um einen Block zu wandern. Und dann haben die Leute halt angefangen, Clock-Cycles zu bauen und Timer und haste nicht gesehen, ne? Und was wirklich, was ich jetzt erst so richtig schnalle, und das habe ich auch so mit einem Kollegen da so besprochen, da ist mir so klar geworden, was das Krasse an diesem Spiel ist. Dieser eine Typ, dieser Markus Persson, der das ursprünglich programmiert hat, der hat sich natürlich gedacht, okay, das wäre ein geiles Spiel, aber der hat natürlich nicht voraussehen können, dass die Arbeit, die er reinsteckt, tausend oder wenn nicht sogar millionenfach wieder angewandt wird, um das Spiel auseinanderzunehmen und zu dekonstruieren. Und alle Bugs und alle Glitches, die aus Versehen oder durch ist einfach so entstanden sind, das nehmen die Leute in unzähligen YouTube-Kanälen, in Wikis, in allem Möglichen zusammen. Das geilste Beispiel war letztens, du kannst halt Schienen bauen, für so Minecarts. Das heißt, wenn du irgendwo tief im Schacht bist und du willst dein Zeug irgendwie schnell nach Hause schicken, kannst du halt eine Strecke bauen. So, das Problem war, man konnte nur Ressourcen damit transportieren. Wenn man selber eingestiegen war, dann war der Dampfwagen, der die ganzen Carts wegschiebt, der war nicht stark genug, um Spieler zu transportieren. Du konntest dich zwar reinsetzen, aber du konntest im Prinzip nur bergab fahren. Und dann haben die Leute rausgefahren, naja Moment, wenn zwei Minecarts auf einer Strecke nebeneinander sich berühren, dann gibt's so einen Clipping-Glitch, dann rappelt's so mit diesem Wagen und der eine schießt unglaublich schnell weg. Und dann haben die angefangen, ok, jetzt im Wiki zu dokumentieren, ok, so baut ihr eine Booster-Track. Da wurde dann immer alle paar Blöcke lang so eine kleine Schleife mit einem wartenden Minecart hingebaut. Und wenn du dran vorbei gerutscht bist, dann hat es kurz so... Dann hat der Typ gesagt, ok, ihr wollt Booster-Tracks, ok, wir bauen Booster-Tracks ins Spiel ein. Dann ist natürlich jetzt die Frage, was sind die besten Booster-Tracks? Booster-Tracks sind relativ teuer zu machen. Man braucht Gold dafür und dieses Redstone und Eisen und Holz. Da haben die angefangen, ok, was ist denn der beste Abstand, um diese Booster-Tracks zu platzieren? Also die maximale Geschwindigkeit ist 8 Meter pro Sekunde. Und dann hat einer halt zum Beispiel, in diesem Blick, der ist auch dokumentiert, hat eine 2 km lange Strecke gebaut und hat Booster-Tracks jeden Block, jeden zweiten, jeden dritten, bis alle 128 Blöcke platziert, hat die Zeit gestoppt und eine Tabelle aufgestellt. Und es stellte sich raus, natürlich jeder Block ist das schnellste, das ist genau 8 Millimeter pro Sekunde, aber durch irgendeinen komischen Coding-Glitch ist jeder 38. Block fast genauso schnell. Und die dazwischen sind langsamer und die danach sind langsamer, genau bei jeder 38. Und die gehen einfach so steil und nehmen alles auseinander. Und es gibt Typen, die verdienen Geld damit. Da gibt es einen Typen, Mambo Jambos, Minecraft-YouTube-Channel, das ist einer der lustigsten tatsächlich. Wer dann immer die verrücktesten Maschinen konstruiert, zum Beispiel eine automatische Baumfarm war letztens. Das war total verrückt. Und zwar gibt es halt eine Schaltung oder es gibt so einen Dispenser. Wenn man da was reinsteckt und einen elektrischen Puls ran setzt, dann alles was da drin ist, wird da einmal so nacheinander rausgefeuert. Und es gibt halt Dünger auch in Minecraft. Und dann hat der halt eine Maschine gebaut, da packst du einen Saatling von einem Baum rein. Dann wird detektiert, dass da ein Saatling ist. Dann schiebt der automatisch den Dünger drauf, bis der Baum da ist. Und schiebt das dann mit Zylindern zur Seite. Und du kannst den nächsten Baum pflanzen. Also es gibt halt auch Zylinder, die man ein- und ausfahren kann und so. Ich weiß nicht, ich schicke dir das erste... Nee, das ist nicht das Richtige. Der Kanal heißt Mambo Jambu. Aber wie gesagt, es gibt halt auch Milliarden Kanäle dafür. Und der Typ ist so ein Britte. Und der hat auch letztens mal sich selber vor die Kamera gestellt und meinte, ich kaufe mir ein Audi S5 bald als nächstes Auto. Und der verdient richtig fett Geld mit so Minecraft-Videos mit Werbung, die er dann dazwischen schaltet. Und ja, genau, diese Videos, die sind auch richtig gut gemacht, muss man sagen. Also richtig, richtig gut mit Intro und Musik. Und der Typ kann erzählen. Also es ist wirklich sehr witzig. Und ja, dieses zum Beispiel da unten in der Mitte oder genau, das ist ein Video, 20 verschiedene Arten eine Tür zu bauen in Minecraft. Das fand ich auch sehr geil. Der war richtig kreativ, weil er dann halt so diese ganzen Maschinen und Zylinder und was nicht noch alles in die absurdesten Kombinationen verbunden hat. Hab ich auch noch nie gesehen. Und hat wahrscheinlich einfach tagelang da dran geschraubt, irgendwie die verrücktesten Türsysteme zu bauen mit allem Möglichen. Ja, hier irgendwie so absolut krasse Maschinen einfach. Und wenn man das halt zu mehreren noch spielt, dann ist das halt noch witziger einfach, weil man eben so sich gegenseitig dann irgendwie... In die Lager gefallen. Das war die letzte Tür, genau.
Also Multiplayer heißt, dass man da auch wirklich mit mehreren gleichzeitig rumläuft, so wie bei World of Warcraft.
Und das Verrückte ist halt auch noch da, da öffnet sich dann ein komplett neues Universum dabei, weil du kannst halt diesen Survival Mode zusammen spielen. Es gibt den Creative Mode, der ist halt nur für die, die bauen wollen. Du hast alle Items unbegrenzt. Im Survival Mode musst du alles, was du bauen willst, musst du auch selber rausholen aus der Erde sozusagen. Das spielen wir auch denen. Und ich finde, das ist auch der, der am meisten Spaß macht. Es gibt aber Leute, die wollen halt nur bauen, das ist der Creative Mode. Und dann gibt es halt auf den Servern, gibt es PvP-Server, weil du kannst dich natürlich mit dem Schwert auch noch gegenseitig hauen. Das heißt, wir haben einen Server-Mod gebaut, wo Minecraft gegeneinander gespielt wird. Und es geht darum, erstens deine Ressourcen zu verteidigen und Fallen gegen die anderen Spieler zu bauen und so viele andere Spieler wie möglich zu killen mit Fall und Bogen und Schwert. Es gibt auch Role-Playing-Server natürlich, wo die so richtig irgendwie abgehen. Es gibt wirklich alle möglichen Spielarten, weil eben auch diese Community so relativ offen ist oder die alle da irgendwie total begeistert sind und darauf abgehen. Und also ich hab immer eigentlich so zwei Spiele gehabt, die ich sehr geschätzt habe, weil die mich irgendwie so total weggeblasen haben. Und jetzt kommt die Fun-Abteilung. Also du guckst jetzt gerade diesen Film an, aber den macht ihr mal Pause, der lenkt ja total ab, Tim. Gleich musst du nämlich auch was erzählen. Oder ihr alle, habe ich mir gerade überlegt. Also für mich gibt es so die Holy Trinity of Computer Games für mich persönlich und die sind natürlich auch unter meinen persönlichen Bewertungskriterien. Und für mich sind das so Spiele, die mich so total das Hirn weggeblasen vor. Wow, da hat jemand so das nächste Level so anlockt, von was kann man mit Spielen auf dem Computer so im Kopf bei den Leuten anstellen? Also die dich irgendwo so anders halt hinbringen und so komplett aus der Realität mal rausreißen, ne? Und das erste Spiel, was das ist, das war halt so nach einer Zeit, wo ich nur bei Freunden irgendwie Monkey Island und so, äh nicht Monkey Island, das heißt schon verraten, verdammt, wo ich so Computerspiele auf dem C64 gespielt habe, hier so Olympics oder irgendwelche Lotus Racer, ne? Und irgendwann kam mal so ein Typ und meinte hier Monkey Island 1. Und dieses Spiel war das erste, was mich total weggeflasht hat. Erstens, weil es so wahnsinnig lustig war. Der Humor, das hatte ich vorher erstens noch keinen Computerspiel, mit der hatte ich viel Humor, so tief gestaffelt in diesem Schwertkampf alleine, dieser Swordfight, wie man da hinkommt. Das war so bescheuert gut, unfassbar. Und halt auch so diese ganze Geschichte, ja du willst jetzt Pirat werden und musst halt mit lauter Leuten schnacken, musst Rätsel lösen, musst halt auch dieses kombinieren, ne? Kombiniere Peitsche mit irgendwie Rumflasche oder so, musstest ja irgendwie immer ganz viel selber auch interagieren. Es gab halt auch immer verschiedene Möglichkeiten an, also es gab keine lineare Handlung komplett. Und das war also das erste Spiel, was mich so da komplett geflasht hat, weil davor kann ich echt nur so diese C64 oder Arcade-Duddle-Spiele, obwohl es davor natürlich auch andere Adventures gab, so Point-and-Click-Adventures, aber Monkey Island war so mein erster Hit. Und das zweite Spiel, also Minecraft ist das dritte, das habt ihr jetzt wahrscheinlich schon gemerkt. Das zweite ist das Metal Gear Solid, was auf der Playstation 1 rauskam und so ein Third-Person-Agentenspiel, wie auch immer, war. Aber das war halt krass, weil da haben wir die DVD reingelegt, oder die CD damals noch. Und dann ging halt so eine Innenspiel-Grafik, so ein Kino-Trailer-Intro los, so mit Credits, mit amtlicher Musik und die einfach sofort gesagt haben, okay, jetzt hier, hier geht's um was sozusagen. Das ist die Story, das ist der Held. Und irgendwie, das war so grünliches Wasser, hast erst nix gesehen, nur die Credits. Und dann schwamm da so dieser Typ da so durch und ging halt so, hat sich von unten an die Basis reingetaucht und die hatten einfach auch nicht einen vollkommen linearen Handlungsstrang. Zweitens, waren die so, die hatten halt auch coolen Humor und sie haben so Sachen gemacht, wie zum Beispiel, du hast gegen einen gekämpft, gegen einen Zwischenboss, der konnte deine Gedanken lesen. Psycho-Mentis hieß der, glaube ich. Und dann meinte der so, hab ich glaube ich auch hier schon mal erzählt, aber ich erzähl's nochmal, kommst du in den Raum und dann so, okay Psycho-Mentis, oh scheiße, Zwischenboss. Und er steht schon so da, okay, lass mich mal dein Gehirn lesen. Ich seh, du bist ein schwacher Kämpfer irgendwie, du hast schon ziemlich oft gespeichert, bist dir nicht so sicher und so. Hat halt geguckt, wie oft du auf deiner Memorycard so auf der Save geklickt hast. Und dann meinte er so, okay, du denkst jetzt wahrscheinlich hier so Psycho und so, du glaubst nicht dran. Und dann, pass mal auf, leg mal deinen Controller auf den Fußboden, ich zeig dir meine Telekinese-Power. Und dann war halt damals in der Playstation gerade der Vibrations-Controller draußen. Dann hast du den auf den Boden gelegt und dann haben die eine Vibration eingeschaltet und dann hat der halt so auf den Boden rumgewarbert und der Typ auf dem Bildschirm halt in so einer düsteren Stimmung halt so, hier, jetzt zeig ich dir mal. Und wir saßen so da nachts so beim Spielen, legen das aus, Parkett und dieses Ding fängt halt an so. Und dann gibt es halt an einer Stelle so den Punkt, da kannst du das Mädel retten oder die Maschine töten und der ist eigentlich um das Spiel geht, ne? Und das Ding ist halt, wenn du die Maschine killst, kriegst du beim nächsten Mal durchspielen, auf dem nächsten Schwierigkeitsgrad, kriegst du den Tarnanzug. Also der wird dir erstmal so ganz fies angeteased und dann so unterm Arsch weggerissen gleich wieder. Und dann heißt es halt so, steht auch irgendwo in dem Handbuch, in dem Storybuch, so wenn du da lang gehst, sozusagen die Maschine killst und das Mädel sterben lässt, kriegst du beim nächsten Mal durchspielen Tarnanzug. Wenn du das Mädel retten gehst, dann kriegst du beim nächsten Mal durchspielen, kannst du in dein Inventory so einen Unendlichkeitsammo-Magazin reinstecken. Und wir so, ja scheiße Tarnanzug, Tarnanzug, ja aber das ist Mädel, das ist Mädel, ja. Und dann kam natürlich der Gentleman in uns raus, ja der Ehrenmann. Und wir haben erst das Mädel gerettet und haben es dann nochmal mit Unendlichkeitsmunition durchgespielt, um dann nochmal den Tarnanzug zu bekommen, um es dann nochmal durchzuspielen. Mit dem Tarnanzug in dieses Spiel, das hat einfach so viele geile Momente drin gehabt. Da musste man auch irgendwann snipern. Und dann hat dir der eine Typ gesagt, ja pass auf, irgendwie deine Hände sind zu zittrig. Hier hast du so ein paar Diazepam und du musst dir irgendwie so Beruhigungsmittel reinpfeifen, damit du überhaupt eine Chance hast gegen hier den Chefsniper und so. Und da sind halt alles so ein bisschen düster, irgendwie auch so mit hier und da.
Also deine Begeisterung in allen Jahren, aber ich frage mich natürlich so ein bisschen, wie jetzt dieses Metal Gear Solid wirklich so dieses neue Weltding irgendwie abfeiert.
Na ja, erstens, weil das halt wie ein spielbarer Film war, das erste Mal, also richtig dich komplett da reingezogen hat in dieses Universum, in dieses ganze Story.
Da gab es jetzt wirklich vorher nichts, was in diese Richtung ging.
Nicht so krass.
Wann, wann ist das? Das ist von?
Also ich fand, das war einfach... Genau, Playstation 1. Das war vor allen Dingen alles in Spiele-Grafik gerendert. Und das hatte ich halt davor so gut, so kinoreif eigentlich von der ganzen Story, von dem ganzen Aufbau mit Spiele-Grafik. Gab es vorher noch nicht. Also die waren halt... Bei Konsolen ist es ja immer so, am Anfang sind die Spiele ja noch nicht am Limit von der Hardware, weil die da halt immer erst so nach und nach so rausfinden, mit welchen Tricks sie da überhaupt alles rausholen können. Und Metal Gear Solid kam meines Wissens oder meiner Erinnerung nach relativ spät auf die Playstation 1. Und die waren halt genau da an diesem Limit. Also das war einfach ein Spiel, was die Plattform so richtig ausgereizt hat. Und alles, was halt ging, eben mit diesem Vibrationscontroller, das gab es ja auch noch nicht am Anfang.
Aber wann war das denn?
Und ich meine, davon gibt es jetzt halt tausende Nachfolgeteile, aber ich fand den ersten Teil, der war einfach so der geilste. Und was halt auch noch bei diesem, weil es ja eigentlich ein Shooterspiel war, was halt auch noch besonders war, eigentlich hast du das Spiel am besten gespielt, wenn du keinen umgebracht hast. Es ging nämlich die ganze Zeit so um Verstecken, um Schleichen, um nicht gehört, nicht gesehen zu werden, so in dem Stil. Und vor allen Dingen, dann gab es halt so Sachen, du bist durch den Schnee gelaufen und es gab immer Wachen. Du hast im Radar gesehen, wo die gerade so hingucken mit ihrem Blickwinkel. Und wenn du halt so durch den Schnee gerannt bist, dann haben die Gegner halt deine Schneespuren gesehen und sind denen auch hinterhergelaufen. Und es war halt so die ganze Zeit so ein Versteckspiel. Du konntest zum Beispiel, wenn du einen großen Pappkarton gefunden hast, in der Basis, konntest du dich unter den Pappkarton setzen und hast du dich diesen runden Schlitz geguckt. Und dann hast du, weil du es ja alles so konntest, und wenn du dann aus der Third-Person-Sicht geguckt hast, konntest du halt so mit diesem Karton so durch die Basis wackeln und dich immer neben so ein Lieferfahrzeug stellen. Dann sind da so die Wachen vorbeigekommen, ich hab mich mal gegengetreten und so, scheiß aus. Weil manchmal haben sie die halt auch verladen, dann ging es halt immer darum, rechtzeitig wieder wegzugehen, damit sie dich nicht auf den Traktor laden. Und es war einfach, ja, war sehr cool gemacht. Und so eine Story-Tiefe, so eine Spieler-Interaktion halt auch mit diesem, wie gesagt, der Psycho-Mendis war jetzt nur ein Beispiel, das hatte ich davor einfach noch nicht. Das war da so in dieses Spiel-Universum reingesaugt worden.
Also das Spiel, also eins der Spiele, was mich total geflasht hat, war Marathon Infinity. Das hatte noch so diese Doom-Grafik mit flachen Gegnern. Aber das krasse...
Kannst du mal immer dazusagen, wo das dazu gehört? Also ich kann das jetzt hier nachschlagen und ich sehe...
Von Bungie war das, genau.
Na, gab's auch Linux und Windows.
Gab's auch auf Classic OS damals schon, ne?
Jaja, es gab's damals für System 6, System 7. Und ich glaube, es gab's...
96.
Jaja, das ist ewig alt. Wie gesagt, es ist so Doom-1-Grafik ungefähr. Aber sehr düster. Man rennt da immer so auf so Raumstationen rum, die irgendwie komplett strange sind. Und die ersten beiden Marathon-Teile waren so ganz ordentlich, aber der dritte war total absurd, weil es ging da irgendwie um so diese übermächtige künstliche Intelligenz, die einen immer ins Spiel beamt, damit man irgendeinen Auftrag erledigt und dann wieder rausbeamt. Und eine davon ist halt wahnsinnig geworden. Und das war ganz absurd, das Spiel. Es geht relativ normal los, und dann kommst du in diesen einen Level, wo kein Gegner drin ist. Der ist komplett dunkel. Du stolperst durch diesen ganzen Level die ganze Zeit, suchst den Ausgang, denkst um die nächste Ecke. Da kommen jetzt aber die Gegner. Weil üblicherweise ist es halt so, da liegt ganz viel Ammo rum. Und dann denkst du so, oh, hier liegt viel Ammo, jetzt muss gleich ein fetter Gegner kommen.
Nix.
Stille, mal so ein paar Geräusche im Hintergrund. Total düster. Und dann rennst du durch, und dann ist der Level zu Ende. Und du denkst so, was war denn das jetzt? Und der nächste Level, der ist dann richtig absurd, weil da kämpfst du plötzlich für die Gegenseite, aber du weißt es nicht. Du wirst in den Level reingebeamt, und plötzlich sind da nur Gegner, aber es sind plötzlich nicht mehr deine Gegner, sondern deine Freunde, und du musst dann die anderen umbringen. Und das hatte so ein paar echt fiese Twists, dieses Spiel, wo es mich jedes Mal gerissen hat.
Diese Seriennudeln, die auch durch wenigstens gut ist.
Naja, Bungie hat irgendwann den Source Code veröffentlicht. Und dann ging es da irgendwie eine Weile lang ab.
Grafisch eher so, naja.
Naja, ich sag ja, das ist so Doom 1-Level.
Ja, aber an allen Spielen, da gab es da reicher Doom 2 schon gezockt.
Quake war ja das erste Spiel mit echten 3D-Gegnern. Da waren die Gegner erstmal auch in 3D.
Mein erster Shooter war Wolfenstein tatsächlich. Na, 3D.
Dieser ganz uralte, mit den Hunden und so?
Mit ohne Boden und ohne Decke, ne?
Dann Duke Nukem Forever, oder dann Ass Doom 1, so irgendwie.
Und so ähnlich fand ich übrigens Half-Life. So das erste Half-Life. Weil das war auch so, da gab es auch so ein paar Level, die relativ leer waren. Und das ist nichts nervenzerreibendes, als wenn du so ein Spiel spielst, du spielst mehrere Level, wo echt viel los ist, und dann kommst du in so ein Level, wo nichts passiert. Und du hast aber das Gefühl, ja, hinter der nächsten Ecke müssen sie aber sein. Sie müssen da einfach sein. Weil das ist die Logik des Spiels, und dann passiert nichts. Ich finde das total nervenaufreibend.
Also was sind denn deine drei Groundbreaking-Spiele, die dein Leben verändert haben, Roddy? Das war auch so deine Frage, oder?
Also das erste Spiel, woran ich mich wirklich gut erinnern kann, das hieß Transylvania auf dem Apple II. Und das war so ein Spiel, das war glaube ich in Basic oder so programmiert, wo so eine Art Grafik, also so eine Grafik-Text-Adventure. Man hat immer Textbefehle eingetippt, es gab einen erklärenden Text und dazu ein Bild. Und dieses Bild wurde aber halt so gezeichnet. Also es hat immer so fünf Sekunden gedauert, bis das Bild irgendwie fertig gezeichnet war.
Das quasi so Vektor-Grafik war, weil man den Platz für Pixel gar nicht hatte.
Genau, das war so, wo irgendwelche Grafikroutinen gezeichnet wurden. Transylvania, gibt es inzwischen auch auf dem iPad. Das hat aber diesen Effekt nicht.
Dauert immer noch fünf Sekunden für den Grafik.
Nee, man kann das auch nicht anschalten, fände ich irgendwie schick. Für die good old times, da gab es einen Vampir und eine Mäuse und ein Goblin und dann musste man eine Silberkugel finden.
Warum war das jetzt sozusagen ein groundbreaking Game?
Weil das das erste Adventure überhaupt war mit Grafik. Also eigentlich auch das erste Text-Adventure, was ich gespielt habe.
Finde ich hier aber nicht fürs iPad. Schreibt sich das mit Trans vielleicht?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Transylvania, so wie man das so schreiben würde.
Ja, ich glaube, so hieß das. Vielleicht habe ich das auf falsche Erinnerungen. Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Also entweder hast du falsche Erinnerungen, dass es das auf dem iPad gibt, oder ist das nur für... Ja, keine Ahnung. Okay, Transylvania, Text-Adventure mit Grafik. Kann ich ja noch folgen.
Ja, da, der Link im Chat, der ist es.
So, so.
Ich glaube, das war's.
Dieser besserwisserische Chat.
Und es gibt iPhone-Versionen auf Transylvania. Auf Rio Mobile Development. Übrigens von Monkey Island 1, da hatte ich ja auch hier schon mal hoch angepriesen, gibt's ja die Special Edition für iOS, sehr zu empfehlen. Da gibt's noch die 8-Bit-Pixel-Grafik und die neue und die vertonte Version, die auch wirklich wunderschön geworden ist. Und das ist ein Spiel, das kann man auch im 21. Jahrhundert noch spielen.
HD oder was?
Ich glaube, das war die Special Edition.
Ja, es gibt ja nur eine Version, die ist das schon.
Ich pack das mal in den Chat.
Also das war so, ja, das war halt so schwarz-weiß-Grafik auf dem Apple II. Damals, das war irgendwie beeindruckend, weil sowas hatte man vorher noch nicht gesehen. Jetzt so rückblickend würde ich das jetzt nicht empfehlen, dass man das spielt, weil es jetzt glaube ich nicht so spannend ist. Aber das war so. Und dann die großen drei? Keine Ahnung. Das ist echt schwierig zu sagen. Ich bin ja nach wie vor ein großer Adventure- und Rätselspielfan. Ach so, ja, dieses Myst fand ich damals auch sehr... Das hat mich eine ganze Woche gekostet. Also da habe ich eine Woche lang nichts anderes gemacht als Myst gespielt. Und dieses Ende ist ein bisschen strange, weil man hat plötzlich am Ende drei Optionen. Und ich wollte es nicht ausprobieren. Ich weiß nicht wieso, ich wollte nicht speichern, das auszuprobieren, sondern ich habe dann einen Tag darüber nachgedacht, was ich tun muss. Und habe dann tatsächlich die richtige Entscheidung getroffen.
Das war so...
Ja, Myst war auch ein ganz schönes Brainfuck-Spiel.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, das geilste Aha-Erlebnis in Myst ist, wenn man feststellt, dass gewisse Geräusche eine Himmelsrichtung anzeigen. Weil da gibt es ein paar Rätsel, die kriegst du viel leichter gelöst, wenn du genau das verstanden hast. Also dieses Rumfahren in dem Untergrund. Da fährst du immer rum, kommst an eine Kreuzung und dann macht es ein bestimmtes Geräusch. Und wenn du weißt, zu welchem Geräusch, zu welcher Himmelsrichtung gehört, dann bist du richtig unterwegs. Und man merkt es aber auf einer ganz anderen Insel, wo dieses Teil sich rotiert. Da macht der nämlich auch immer dieses Geräusch, wo es zu einer bestimmten Himmelsrichtung gehört. Das war auch so ein super AHA-Erlebnis.
Hier, da ist der Link, der untere. Also ich hab die Special Edition von Monkey Island, die es für das iPad anscheinend nur gibt. Ich glaub, die gibt es auch für das iPad. Und da ist Transylvania, der unterste Link da im Chat. Klick da nochmal drauf, dann siehst du auch die Optik da. Sehr hübsch ist das. Nee, der ganz, oder der? Doch. Nee, nee, ganz unten im Chat.
Und das hat schon immer so zwei, drei Sekunden gedauert auf dem Apple II, bis er so ein Bild fertig gezeichnet hat.
Ja, das weiß ich aber auch noch so mit so Fill-Routinen und so weiter. Im Prinzip diese ganzen Basic-Paints.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es wirklich ein Basic war, aber man sah, das waren wirklich...
Ja, meistens ist es das so, richtig so Linien ziehen und damit machst du quasi so deinen 3D-Kram und dann Paint irgendwie... Das kenne ich auch so einige, die das so gemacht haben. Ich bin auch so ein Spiele-Agnostiker, das kannst du dir überhaupt nicht vorstellen. Also für mich gibt es halt auf diesem Planeten nur 5 Spiele.
Ach, 5 jetzt schon?
2048.
Was denn, das mit dem Auto, das mit der Wumme, das mit...
Ja, da wo man alle erschießen muss, da wo man die Prinzessin retten muss.
Ja gut, das überschneidet sich aber mitunter.
Ja, das ist auch nicht so genau definiert. Aber diese ganzen... Ich laufe durch die Gegend und schieße alle um. Also der Reiz dieser Spiele auf mich war negativ. Also das hat mich nicht nur nicht angezogen, es hat mich einfach abgeschreckt. Ich wollte mich dem überhaupt nicht nähern. Also ich hab, glaub ich, mal Doom gespielt.
Doom selber fand ich ein bisschen öde, muss ich sagen.
Na ja gut, das war halt so mal aus Interesse, um mal so zu wissen, wovon man redet. Okay, da hat man vielleicht mal eine Stunde reingesteckt, oder zwei, ich weiß es nicht mehr so ganz genau. Aber so, dass ich dann so völlig brannte für dieses Genre, kann ich echt nicht behaupten. Ich mag so Games, die irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, ich hab so ein paar Spiele jahrelang gespielt. Also so ganz einfache, super einfache 2D-Games im Idealfall auch noch. Also schon 3D habe ich irgendwie nicht so richtig mitgemacht. Das war mir irgendwie alles viel zu... Ich glaube, nahezu alle Spiele, die ich spiele, sind zweidimensional.
Keine Ahnung, Boulder Dash, das war damals schön.
Ja, kenn ich auch noch, das war nett. Aber dass mich jetzt wirklich irgendwas, ich weiß nicht, mich haben Spiele auch so ein bisschen abgeturnt damals. Das war zwar schon an sich, okay, man kann das machen, und klar, man spielt zusammen, und was weiß ich, auf dem C64 hab ich glaub ich ewig Jumpman gespielt und so. Aber was Spiele mir eigentlich wirklich gesagt haben damals war, das ist nicht das, was ich machen will mit dem Computer. Sondern ich will die programmieren. Also für mich war Spielen auf dem Computer, das war das, was die anderen machen. Ja, und ich wollte verstehen, wie die Büchse funktioniert.
Ja, ich weiß, es gab damals Leute, die haben irgendwie die Spiele dann auch gesammelt, und irgendwann ab 2000 Spielen das Zählen aufgehört. Das war auch nicht so mein Ding, sondern das...
Ja, und ich will das gar nicht abwerten. Also das ist mir vollkommen bewusst, dass da eine Menge Kreativität freigesetzt wird, und dass natürlich auch Spieleprogrammierung eine echte Kunst ist. Und in gewisser Hinsicht beneide ich auch Leute, die so drehbuchartig solche Welten so entwerfen können. Ich könnte auch keinen Film drehen, ich könnte kein Theaterstück schreiben in dem Sinne, weil das gibt meinen Hirn irgendwie nicht so richtig her. Aber auch mein Wunsch, diesen Spielen zu folgen, also ich hab häufiger mal was mit, was irgendwas angefangen, was ich müsste, hab ich auch mal angefangen zu spielen, aber meine Bereitschaft, diese Spiele weiter zu spielen, endet meistens sehr früh. Also ich verzweifle an irgendeinem Detail, und dann denk ich mir so...
Also ich mag Grafik-Adventures aller Art immer noch sehr gerne, also wenn sie gut gemacht sind natürlich. Ich hatte ja irgendwie vor zwei oder drei Sendungen mal eins gepluggt von diesem deutschen Entwickler. Das müsste jetzt dann demnächst auch irgendwann mal fertig sein. Zumindest war der Kickstarter irgendwie, oder was, das war erfolgreich.
Also ich hab ja nun auch schon ein paar Jahre Zocken hinter mir.
Ich weiß, das ist ein Spiel mit einem W und einem O und einem W wahrscheinlich.
Also World of Warcraft hab ich ja nun wirklich lange gezockt, das muss man einfach erwähnen, das ist schon auch aus damaliger Gesicht. Muss man sich ja vorstellen, alle haben ewig irgendwie Rollenspiele gespielt, aber halt so in 3D und in Live und in der Größe und so weiter, das gab's einfach nicht, also World of Warcraft. Und das war schon ein Ereignis. Ein Kumpel von mir hat da, glaube ich, schon, weiß nicht wie viel, 10 Jahre, 15 Jahre darauf gewartet auf dieses Game. Und kam dann zu mir, meinte, hier, Dennis, musst du ihn mal angucken? Und ich war jetzt gar nicht überzeugt und meinte, na, hier, mach dir mal eine Figur und ich geh da mal, du kannst ja noch ein bisschen zocken. Das war ungefähr wie mit deinem Kumpel mit Minecraft. Ich hab ja gar nicht mehr aufgehört und er hat gar nicht so lange gezockt und ich dann irgendwie, na ja, durch oder so. Keine Ahnung. Das war ziemlich cool. Ansonsten, die letzten Jahre, was ich richtig cool fand, weil es mal auch ein bisschen anders war, ist Portal. Das fand ich irgendwie, weil das ist halt so ein bisschen, ist ja kein wirklich ein First-Person-Shooter, aber es ist halt ein First-Person-Game. Und dieses Rätelrat und wie schaff ich da jetzt was, ist da so intelligent und gut gemacht. Und wenn du es erstmal spielst und dann noch hier diese Championship oder diese schwereren Level, ich weiß nicht, wie die genau genannt werden, wo dir die Rätsel noch mal, du musst zum Ziel kommen mit besonders wenig Portalen oder besonders schnell oder mit besonders wenig, dass du dich selber bewegst, sondern viel Portals benutzt. Das ist einfach der Hammer, was es dafür Tricks gibt, auch wenn man das nicht schafft und sich da bei YouTube anguckt, was die sich haben einfallen lassen, um das so zu lösen, ist der Wahnsinn. Das macht wirklich viel Spaß. Und dann gibt es ja noch Portal 2, wo noch ein bisschen was dazu kommt, aber eigentlich Portal 1 ist einfach top. Und die ganzen First-Person-Dinger, da hab ich ja auch eine Menge gezockt, also irgendwie Quake 3 zu mehreren Leuten, hat einfach Spaß gemacht. Das hat man damals noch nicht über Internet gespielt, sondern hat man sich noch getroffen, Rechner mitgeschleppt, Mini-Netzwerk aufgebaut.
Ich hab das über Mode, über ESDN konnte man das richtig gut spielen. Da war der Ping so schön niedrig, da konnte man sogar...
Nee, ich bin immer mit dem Rechner zum Kumpel, haben wir einmal so eine Nacht gemacht irgendwie. Und ich weiß, wir haben wirklich bis in die Morgenstunden gespielt und das war so ein Spaß. Du kriegst da so ein Adrenalin-Fleisch, du bist plötzlich so schnell, du kannst das gar nicht denken. Du springst dann und fängst an, noch beim Springen irgendwie deine Rakete abzufeuern, während du dich noch umdrehst, damit du wieder richtig landest und gleich wieder weiter renn kannst. Weil irgendwann, ja, musst du einfach so schnell sein, damit du nicht gleich immer sofort von den anderen gekillt wirst. Und das war echt richtig cool. Davon halt noch eine ganze Menge Spiele von diesen Dingern. Auch dieses Wolfenstein von vor zehn Jahren. Nicht das ganz alte, sondern was vor zehn Jahren so rauskommt, also das Vorvorletzte. Und jetzt aktuell, gerade noch um es abzuschließen, spiele ich Ghost Recon Phantoms heißen die. Das ist auch ein Third-Person-Shooter. Also man sieht sich selbst ein bisschen, oder? Third-Person-Shooter. Und das ist immer 8 gegen 8, online halt. Und du kannst auch so Vierergruppen bilden, du kannst Clans bilden. Und du musst dann immer so Maps erobern. Die Maps sind teilweise spiegelgedingst hier. Oder halt auf beiden Seiten unterschiedlich. Und man spielt dann immer zwei Runden. Einmal von einer Seite und dann einmal von der anderen Seite, damit das nicht ungleich wirkt. Und du musst irgendwie so Punkte erobern. Es gibt immer 5 Punkte oder manchmal nur 3. Du musst jedenfalls alle kriegen und dich immer so vorarbeiten. Und da muss man schon... Die haben die Waffen ziemlich genau implementiert. Aber man muss trotzdem schon auch mit Taktik vorgehen und seine Devices irgendwie zum richtigen Zeitpunkt einsetzen und so. Und das macht auch einen tierischen Spaß. Ich weiß nicht warum, aber... Herr Mordsgaudi. Also da ist es immer schön... Also du wirst halt tierisch oft erschossen, aber manchmal ist es cool, du kommst so zum Gegner und der guckt gerade in eine andere Richtung und du kannst ihn so richtig schön in Ruhe umballern. Das sind eigentlich aber die spaßigsten Momente, wo du halt als Sniper bist und da endlich mal einer ganz woanders hinguckt und nicht weiß, dass du ihn jetzt wegballern wirst und du in Ruhe deinen Schuss absetzen kannst, dann macht es auch echt eine Menge Fun. Oder wenn du manchmal kommst, so ich weiß nicht, wie es ist, aber da komme ich dann so in Berserker-Modus und renne mit so einer Submaschinen-Gun durch die Gegend und balle alle um, wo ich denke, eigentlich hättest du schon längst tot sein müssen. Aber irgendwie, wahrscheinlich weil man im Berserker-Modus ist, ist man so weit vorne, dass die Gegner gar nicht damit rechnen, dass du dir schon da rumhängst und die rennen dir alle vor die Flinte und wissen gar nicht, was ihnen geschieht. Das ist auch ziemlich cool. Das Spiel hieß Ghost Recon Phantoms. Früher hieß es Ghost Recon Online, haben sie dann umbenannt. Früher hieß es Gros, jetzt heißt es GRP sozusagen. Das ist ein Free-to-Play und viele meckern, dass die Kids oder wer auch immer, dass sie sich mit Paypal die dicken Waffen kaufen und dann rumrennen und alles wegballern. Das kommt mir teilweise auch so vor, aber man kann sich da auch hoch kämpfen, ohne dass man irgendein Fennich investiert. Und wenn man von einem angenommenen Kid mit guter Waffe weggeballert wird, dann ist es halt so. Aber ich denke, man kann da schon, wenn man einigermaßen spielen kann, ganz gut mithalten. Man wird auch eingestuft in Gruppen, wie gut man ist. Das heißt, man hat nicht immer voll die ultraschweren Gegner, sondern immer ungefähr in der Schwierigkeit, in der man selber spielt. Und man muss da nicht investieren, wenn man nicht will. Ich hab da noch keinen Fennich bisher investiert. Und ich spiele das immer mit einem Kumpel zu zweit online und wir haben da tierischen Spaß manchmal. Und manchmal losen wir halt voll ab und dann haben wir halt wieder auf. Aber das macht irgendwie fun.
Also was ich hier in letzter Zeit, oder was ich so als letztes so gespielt hab, war diese Assassin's Creed Reihe. Von der zwei aufwärts.
Das muss ja auch die gleiche Führbar sein wie Ghost Recon Phantoms, weil das ist von Obi, richtig? Weil das ist nämlich auch diese AC, diese Assassin's Creed Waffen irgendwie, die haben da so eine Adlerspitze irgendwie. Die haben da so eine Kapuzeart mit so einer Spitze von so einem Vogel irgendwie. Und diese Waffen gibt es auch bei Ghost Recon Phantoms.
Was bei Assassin's Creed ganz cool ist, ist, dass es eine relativ offene Welt ist, in der du einfach so rumrennst, wenn du nicht gerade irgendwie an dem Hauptquest am Machen bist. Und kannst du auch Sightseeing machen oder kannst halt, weiß ich nicht, kleinere Nebenaufträge erledigen oder einfach nur an Gebäuden rumklettern oder so. Das ist eigentlich immer ganz schön, weil man echt gucken kann. Weil sie sich auch immer wieder interessante Städte aussuchen, also Florenz in der Renaissance und Venedig in der Renaissance, dann Rom, Konstantinopel. Jetzt bei Teil 3 war Amerika, da gehört der Gründerzeit dran mit dem ganzen Unabhängigkeitskrieg. Teil 4 ist jetzt in der Karibik und der Teil 5, der ist noch nicht draußen, aber der soll zur französischen Revolution in Paris spielen. Und die Videos, die sie so veröffentlicht haben, die sehen schon verdammt geil aus. Das wird bestimmt ziemlich Spaß machen. Also bis Assassin's Creed 3 würde so ein etwas neuerer Mac reichen. Das 4, was ich jetzt auf meinem alten Powerbook mit einem Core i7 spiele, das hat schon so leichte Ruckelanfälle. Aber es geht gerade noch. Ich weiß nicht, was du für Assassin's Creed 5 brauchen wirst. Das läuft dann auch nur noch auf der PS4.
Gegen andere brauchst du immer eine schnelle Kiste, weil jede zehntel Sekunde, die du etwas schneller siehst und die das nicht ruckelt, ist einfach ein Zeitgewinn. Das war ja auch schon bei den Shootern immer so, wer den besten Ping hat, das ist der, der gewinnt.
Ich spiele das ja nicht im Multiplayer, insofern ist das egal.
Bei den Multiplayern ist das halt so. Bei deinem Spiel ist es ja so, dass man rechts unten haben will, damit es besonders schick aussieht, weil es geht ja um die Optik. Was ich ja auch gespielt hab, war Crysis 2 von dieser Bude, die gerade so ein bisschen den Bach runtergeht, nämlich Crytek.
Die gehen den Bach runter?
Ja, die haben noch ihre Leute in England, die kriegen kein Geld und die flüchten gerade alle, also denen da munkelts gerade, dass es denen gar nicht so richtig gut geht. Und dieses Crysis 2, das ist so zwei, drei Jahre her, das ist eigentlich ganz cool, sehr grafisch, sehr geil, wir haben wirklich eine gute Engine und das Spiel hat auch Spaß gemacht. Aber das Problem war dann doch, dass irgendwie das schon so ein bisschen so, wie nennt man die Spiele, die dir auf so schienen, so Track Games, also die auf so eine Art... Genau, wo du, du kannst halt nicht so links und rechts vom Fahrt irgendwie mal in so eine Seitenstraße gehen, also das Spiel spielt da in New York. Du musst halt schon immer irgendwie dem Track nach, deren Skript irgendwie langlaufen und erst, wenn du an einer bestimmten Stelle angekommen bist, dann wurde wieder das ausgelöst und dann kamen neue Monster, in dem Fall der Außerirdische und so weiter. Das Spiel hat Spaß gemacht und sah auch wirklich schick aus, aber dass es so Rail-mäßig war, das hat ein bisschen genervt und ich glaube, das ist vielleicht auch, ich vermute es mal, so ein bisschen der Untergang, warum die vielleicht jetzt pleite gehen, weil deren Spiele irgendwie zu eintönig waren.
Das ist mit diesem Spiel, wo man die ganze Zeit Leute vergewaltigen muss und Autos klauen.
Hab ich nie gespielt, war nicht mein Ding. War das nicht auch ein Konsolenspiel, oder ist das Windows?
Gibt es auch auf dem Rechner, auf allen Plattformen.
So was hab ich nie gezockt.
Das ist aber glaube ich eher so Open-World-mäßig. Also wenn man Spaß an sowas hat, ist das bestimmt nicht verkehrt.
War nie meins.
GTA 1 war halt, das war tatsächlich auch so ein Spiel. Bei irgendeiner Spielezeitschrift war das dabei. Das war ja noch so von Draufsichten mit Pixel-Grafik oder so mit so Bitmap-Grafik. Und das hab ich halt so von dieser Demo-CD von der Spielezeitschrift ausprobiert und dachte, ja was ist das denn? Aber das hat erstaunlich viel Spaß gemacht. Also lange Zeit hat mir GTA schon sehr viel Spaß gemacht, aber irgendwann war es auch wieder gut.
Half Life 2 haben sie auch im Club viel gespielt, als es gerade rauskam. Da wurden dann die dicken Rechner angeschleppt und haben wieder Half Life auf dem Beamer gespielt oder irgendwie so.
Naja, aber das ist ja auch bei jedem, deswegen hab ich ja so eine Runde gefragt, weil jeder ja sowieso andere Präferenzen hat und die eine Hitliste ist nicht die Hitliste von einem anderen, aber Minecraft, da braucht man keine gute Hard-Verfüllung, ist ja alles 8-Bit-Pixel-Grafik und man kann irgendwie seinen eigenen Spielmodus bestimmen und das finde ich halt.
Also wenn man das Spiel startet, muss man sich hier einloggen.
Das kostet halt Geld, das Spiel. Und du musst ja halt... Also am Anfang in der Alpha-Version hat es 5 Dollar gekostet. Er meinte, wenn es zur Beta kommt, dann kostet es 10. Wenn es zur Gamma oder Alpha Beta kommt, dann kostet es 15. Und wenn wir es wirklich final releasen, kostet es 20 Dollar. Und jetzt kostet es heutzutage 20 Dollar.
Für Pro was?
Für immer einfach.
Der ist ja auch Millionär geworden, relativ schnell.
Ich habe es für 10 Dollar in der Beta-Phase gekauft. Und als ich es letztens wieder gestartet habe, ging das auch immer noch. Und das wird auch immer gehen. Ich glaube, das war schon immer die Ansage, du kaufst es einmal. Du kannst unendlich updates, du kannst dir das Server-Ding runterladen und kannst machen, was du willst dann damit. Und da musst du jetzt halt vorher dir wahrscheinlich so einen Account auf der Webseite klicken mit Paypal und dann...
Die updaten ja auch, weil diese neuen Devices, die da rauskommen, da geht ja immer mehr von diesen, wie man Sachen zusammenstellen kann. Und da passiert ja richtig was.
Ja, und die haben es ja auf Xbox geportet, auf iOS gibt es Minecraft mittlerweile. Und die machen weiterhin richtig viel Asche. Und es ist einfach so ein geiles Spiel, weil kein Spiele-Publisher ever würde so ein Spiel rausbringen. Mit der Optik, mit den Mechaniken, mit keinem Ziel. Es gibt ja keinen Endboss in dem Sinne, oder wo du das Spiel beendest. Ja, das ist wirklich... das ist bestimmt so alles selber. Da würde dir jeder sagen, ne, das gibt es nicht. Und schon gar nicht zu dem Preis. Und der hat das halt rausgehauen. Ich glaube, es gibt auch auf lange Zeit einfach keinen Klon davon, weil das einfach so eine einzigartige, kleine, schrullige, komische Kiste ist, die einfach so viel Liebe erfährt und die sich halt der Community gegenüber einfach auch so cool verhalten. Dass eben diese Glitches, die die Leute ausnutzen, dann irgendwann sagen, ja okay, wir machen mal einen Feature draus. Es scheint ja großen Bedarf zu geben und so. Statt halt zu sagen, nein, wir verbieten das, das darf nicht sein und so.
Ich bin ja gespannt, was als World of Warcraft Nachfolger kommt, weil da gibt's zwar lauter Sachen wie Guild Wars und so weiter, aber ich hab immer das Gefühl, die leben irgendwie nicht so lange. Die Welten sind viel kleiner, auch wenn World of Warcraft schon sinkende Spielerzahlen hat, weil die hatten auch verdammt viele Spieler, die da monatlich Kohle zahlen. Aber ich bin gespannt, was da als Nachfolger kommt, weil World of Warcraft selbst haben die wohl auch, bevor es rauskam, haben die Anfang 2000, glaube ich, angefangen zu coden. Ende 2004 kam das Beta raus oder so. Also die haben da schon vier, fünf Jahre dran geschrieben und leveldesigned, bevor das Spiel fertig war. Und deswegen frage ich mich, wann das wirklich ein nächstgroße Ding irgendwie kommt, weil bisher ist da noch nichts zu sehen. Hat eigentlich einer von euch hier dieses andere Spiel gespielt, was dann im Weltraum stattfindet, was so ein bisschen World of Warcraft ähnlich ist, aber wo es keine Ziele gibt, sondern man machen kann, was man will? Da gab es noch mal eine ganz andere Liga.
Da gab es so ein tolles Diagramm zu Lernkurven in Spielen. Und das eine ging halt so flach und hoch, und das andere gleich hoch und dann flacher. Und bei EVE Online war es so...
Großer Spaghettiknoten.
Übrigens, ich hab mal parallel nachgeschaut, was Schindluder eigentlich heißt. Als Luder bezeichnet man in der Hegersprache ein totes Tier, das zum Anlocken von Raubtieren verwendet wird. Das Luder wird an einem sogenannten Luderplatz ausgelegt. Inzwischen werden solche Luderplätze von Naturschützern angelegt. So was. Und als Schindluder wurde früher totes oder krankes Vieh bezeichnet, das zum Abdecker gebracht wurde. Und der Abdecker ist ein Typ, der sich mit dem Beseitigen von toten Tieren und so beschäftigt. Achso, und der heißt Schinder auch umgangssprachlich. Also das Schindluder ist quasi das Viech, was du da zu dem Schinder bringst. Und ist auf jeden Fall, glaube ich, zur Entsorgung.
Der Abdecker, der sorgt für neue und entsorgt die alten.
Ich lese aus der Wikipedia vor, der für den Chat fragt. Schinder Hannes, Feld- oder Fallmeister, Luderführer. Habe ich vorhin gesagt. Hatt ich irgendwie noch das Tab offen, denn gerade als ich hier meine ganzen Spieletabs zugemacht habe, kam das wieder in den Vordergrund. Aber Minecraft zum Beispiel, ich glaube das ist auch für Kids einfach wirklich super geil, weil das ist einfach so wie Lego nur mit unendlich Steinchen.
Vor allem kannst du ja von einem kleinen Kind auch zum großen Kind werden und dann halt eben deine Schaltung da einbauen. Oder was auch immer.
Kathedrale bauen.
Ja, alles. Also du kannst wirklich... Es gibt schier endlose Möglichkeiten. Deswegen meinte ich ja, es gibt auch immer was zu tun, weil du denkst dir so, jetzt habe ich das gebaut und jetzt kann ich das machen und mit dem was ich jetzt machen kann, kann ich eigentlich das nächste bauen. Aber dafür bräuchte ich noch dies und das und jenes.
Ich würde auch sagen, dass für Kinder ist wahrscheinlich so ein First-Person-Shooter halt nicht gut, weil da ballert halt man nur rum, sondern da ist eher wieder sowas wie Boulder Dash, wo halt man gucken muss, wie sich die Figuren da bewegen. Die einen, die sich immer rechts lang bewegen, die anderen, die auf jeden Fall immer links lang abbiegen oder wo aus den Steinchen, wenn sie auf Diamanten fallen, dann neu entstehen oder die kaputt machen. Je nachdem, wo man halt so ein System und wo man Regeln irgendwie entdecken und verstehen muss. Das ist für Kinder, glaube ich, genau das Richtige und die haben mir auch immer eine Menge Spaß gemacht. Ich hab auf einem Amiga, hab ich mit einem Kumpel immer Emerald Mine gespielt. Das war so ein Boulder-Dash-Nachmacht-Ding. Und da konnte man immer, da gab es 80 Level und da wurde pro Level immer der, der am schnellsten war und am meisten Punkte hatte, der wurde mal in diese Highscore eingetragen. Und hab ich das immer mit meinem Kumpel gespielt, mit einer Diskette, er hatte in meinem gleichen Haus gewohnt, ganz unten. Und je nachdem, der die Diskette gerade hatte, der konnte das zocken, weil wir wollten halt eine Highscore haben. Und dann hat er halt bei einem bestimmten Level, den ich voll gut konnte, wo jeder Schritt saß und ich alle Punkte holte, und sofort zum Ende kam, und so schnell war ich noch nie, und dann gibt er mir das Ding ab und der war wieder dann irgendwie eine Zehntelsekunde schneller oder so. Und das war wirklich so, da musst du jedes Mal, wenn du dich bewegst mit dem Joystick so, das musst du jetzt einmal falsch gelaufen und du konntest gleich aufhören, weil du hast den Rekord nicht mehr geschafft. Und ich hab mir das vor ein paar Jahren mal angeguckt und hab das mal versucht, nochmal so zu zocken, weil ich wusste noch ungefähr, wie ich gelaufen bin, aber keine Chance mehr. Jetzt kriegst du nie wieder hin, was da an Zeit investiert wurde, wie man am besten da langläuft und was der schnellste Weg ist. Das ist ja so ein bisschen so, wie man versucht, das rauszufinden hier mit dem Geschäftsreisender, der an allen Stellen hin muss. Das Problem des Geschäftsreisenders, wie heißt das? Genau, und da musst du auch zu allen hin, aber du musst halt den schnellsten Weg finden und dann zum Ausgang und irgendwie so. Und gleichzeitig, dass die Viecher dich nicht erwischen. Und das war schon krass, was wir da an Zeit investiert haben und rausgefunden haben, wie die wann wo langrennen und so weiter und so fort. Das hat auch echt eine Menge Spaß gemacht.
Dieses Dekonstruieren von Spielen, einfach so dieses Auseinandernehmen, diese Verhältnisse und Gesetzmäßigkeiten wieder rausziehen und daraus eigene Vorteile wieder schnitzen. So, das war doch ein ganz lebhaftes Thema.
Ja, zu dem ich leider herzlich wenig beitragen kann.
Also du konntest ein kleines Schläfchen halten.
Ich hatte auch nie in meinem Leben einen Computer, auf dem man Spiele spielen konnte so richtig. Also auf dem man so richtig State-of-the-Art-Spiele spielen konnte.
Na, also für die ganzen PC-Dinger hatte ich halt hier meine Bitcoin-Mining-Software, die Grafikkarten halt benutzt. Da hab ich halt dieses Crysis 2 braucht, halt richtig viel Rechenpower. Das hab ich teilweise auf drei 58-70 Grafikkarten hier so mit diesem Crossfire mit zweimal verbunden irgendwie gezockt. Und das tat eigentlich ganz gut.
Ja, aber auf dem Mac gab's ja eigentlich nie so richtig Spiele. Command und Conker, Game-Konsole.
Command und Conker auch ne Menge gezockt mit dem kleinen Rambo-Typen, der dann so ne Rambo-Mission machen musste.
Command und Conker lief halt auf dem Mac als erstes auf SVGA. Da hatte ich meinen Power-PC-Mac und die ganzen PC-Loser, die mussten noch VGA spielen.
Aber da muss man auch alle erschießen, oder nicht?
Ja, aber es war ja ein Einsatz-Spiel.
Oder Populous, kennste noch Populous? Da war man so Gott und da war so eine Insel im Meer. Und damit deine Figürchen, also die Menschen da unten auf der Insel, damit die halt Brot oder was auch immer hier anpflanzen konnten, musstest du denen so die Erde flach machen. Und dann konnten die so Häuser bauen. Und gleichzeitig war da halt, ich glaube, da war auch ein anderer Gott und eine andere Insel und gegen die hast du gespielt. Und du musstest halt dafür sorgen, dass deine Insel halt und deine Mannequins, dass die reich waren oder Geld hatten oder gute Häuser bauen konnten. Und dann konntest du bei dem Gegend auch immer Plagen und Sümpfe hinstellen und irgendwie einen Vulkan oder weiß gar nicht mehr, was da genau ging. Flut oder sonstige und das war auch sehr spaßig. War auf jeden Fall auch schon ein Zerstörerspiel, aber auch ein, musstest auch kreieren irgendwie. Black and White kam schon später, das war von dem gleichen Typen wie von Populous, aber Black and White hab ich nie gespielt. Da war irgendwas mit Kühen, weiß ich nur noch. Aber ist auch schon ewig her.
Hier in Civilization, einer der anderen Klassiker, hast du auch nicht gespielt, Tim?
Oder SimCity, weil das ist der Vorgänger von Minecraft, könnte man ja fast sagen. Du musstest einfach ne Stadt machen, oder?
Keine Ahnung, ich hab jetzt grad mal Minecraft gemacht, ich bin gestorben, hab Score Null.
Das ist so etwa der Level, auf den ich spiele. Das haben alle bei Minecraft am ersten...
Ja, bei mir geht's immer so.
Aber das wird besser.
Ich kann mich noch nicht mal an ein Spiel erinnern, was ich zu Ende gespielt hab.
Ist aber bei einem Spiel noch eher schwer.
Oder hab ich irgendwie mal irgendwas zu Ende gekriegt?
Ich bin auch nicht so ein zu-endes-Spieler.
Mist, war das erste Spiel, was ich tatsächlich zu Ende gespielt hab. Und irgendwie...
Monkey Island war mein erstes, doch. Aber das hat echt Blut und Schweiß gekostet, weil damals gab's noch nicht das Internet, wo man sich so ein Walkthrough oder so eine Lösung durchlesen konnte. Sondern wenn man Glück hatte, wenn die Sterne sich aligned haben, und irgendwie alles in der richtigen Konstellation war, dann hat irgendeine Spielezeitschrift genau zu dem Punkt, wo man gerade war, ein Walkthrough veröffentlicht. Und man hat es rechtzeitig erfahren und hat diese Spielezeitschrift gekauft. Ansonsten saß ich und mein Kumpel vor diesem Monkey Island.
Wie kriegen wir dieses Schwert?
Und haben tausende Sachen einfach ausprobiert, wie man vielleicht den Geschäftsbesitzer dazu bekommt, uns ein Schwert zu geben. Und dann war es so eine einfache Lösung am Ende. Ja, das ist einfach...
Vielleicht fällt mir noch irgendein Spiel ein.
Du musst halt mit leichteren Spielen anfangen.
2048 hast du doch zu Ende gespielt.
In der 2048 spiele ich, seitdem du das erwähnt hast.
Immer noch? Du bist also kein Zocker, ne?
So, so.
Nee, für mich ist 2048 etwas, das mache ich, während ich etwas anderes tue.
In einer Postschlange stehen oder so?
Nee, es ist zum Beispiel super, während ich einen Podcast höre, um mich einfach visuell abzulenken. Außerdem muss ich natürlich unbedingt, also ich war mal sehr gut, dann gab es irgendwie so eine schwäche Phase, die ich jetzt wieder noch nicht so richtig überwunden habe. Und ich will einfach mal sechsstellig werden und muss unbedingt mal diese 8192 endlich mal auf den Tisch kriegen. Und irgendwie gelingt es mir nicht. Ja, aber das ist ja mal so die intellektuelle Level, auf dem so ein Spiel mit mir ganz gut funktioniert. Da ist schon dieses Fries irgendwie, diese Diskussion hat man ja schon, das mir dann schon wieder viel zu verkoppt.
Mit einer Drei und so, ich bitte euch.
Die schönsten Spiele sind eigentlich die, die wenig Regeln haben, aber wodurch voll viel entstehen kann. Und eigentlich Minecraft ist ja auch so ein Ding. Hat jetzt schon inzwischen eine Menge Steinchen, aber eigentlich die kreiert man aus den anderen Sachen. Also hat eigentlich so ein Grundset und das finde ich gut. Deswegen bin ich auch so ein Marvel Madness, nicht Marvel Madness, ein Load Runner Fan. Weil da geht nicht viel, aber wenn man sich die Level später anguckt, da sind schon noch ein paar echt schwere Dinger dabei.
Gut, dann haben wir das mit den Spielen, glaube ich, jetzt ausreichend gewürdigt. Mal gucken, vielleicht überzeugt mich ja nochmal irgendwas davon, aber ich glaube, bei mir ist irgendwie Hopfen und Malz verloren.
Nächste Sendung kommt Tim so, Transylvania. Das ist ja das geilste Spiel aller Zeiten.
Aber vielleicht mal ein Detail noch, wo du gerade meintest, bei Metal Gear Solid, dass du da vor dieser rumreichen Fragestellung standest, ob du jetzt...
Das Girl oder den Endgegner?
Das Girl oder den Endgegner. Für wer es noch nicht gesehen hat, sollte man definitiv sich mal anschauen. Man hat schon so einen gewissen Bekanntheitsgrad und sollte es meiner Meinung nach auch haben. Und zwar ist das hier aus dem Kanal Feminist Frequency. Wie heißt die Dame noch gleich? Ach, verdammte Küche. Steht der Name hier irgendwo? Genau, Anita Sarkisian. Das ist die junge Dame, die das spricht.
Dumbbell in Distress Part 1, Tropes vs.
Genau, das ist mittlerweile schon eine etwas längere Serie. Mit diesem Dumbbell in Distress Part 1 fing es halt an. Und das ist halt so eine ausführliche Analyse darüber, wie dieses, also hier heißt es, ja hier ist von einem Klischee und Trope die Rede, so dieses irgendwie Mädchen müssen unbedingt gerettet werden. So, ja, dass das einfach so nahezu in jedem Spiel ein Thema...
Was wird hier Legend of Zelda und so weiter?
Es kommt da sehr viel zur Sprache. Es ist also einfach so eine Aufstellung, wie sich das so entwickelt hat und wie das in einzelnen Spielen umgesetzt ist, welche Varianten das so hat und so weiter. Es ist wirklich erstaunlich, ja. Es gibt dann auch einen, also ich kann das jetzt nicht mehr so ganz auswendig rübergeben. Schmeiß mal den Link. Es gibt da noch einen zweiten und vielleicht sogar noch einen dritten Teil, oder war das dann schon, wo sie sich eines anderen Themas gewidmet hat? Ich... Genau, Dumsland Distress. Genau, da gibt es drei Teile von... Ach Gott, den hab ich schon länger nicht mehr hinbekommen. Also da gibt es viel zu, viel zu nachzuhören. So und ich meine, das ist ja...
Und hat sie sich auch beschwert, dass die Bösewichter immer Typen sind?
Beschwert? Naja, ich meine, es geht ja hier erstmal um eine Analyse. Also es ist einfach wirklich eine analytische Arbeit, die einfach diese ganze Spielewelt auseinandernimmt und ich finde es auch sehr gut gemacht. Und lässt sich halt nicht leugnen, dass so die Mädchenrolle in Computerspielen einfach eine sehr schwierige ist. Weil es halt einfach immer wieder dieselben Muster sind, die du findest und es ist teilweise zum Lachen und teilweise einfach nur noch zum Heulen, wenn man sich diese Aufstellung anschaut. Also würde ich mal sehr empfehlen, zumindest mal in diese ersten drei Teile reinzulauschen. Das gibt einem doch eine Menge. Ist natürlich ein Objekt wildester Beschimpfungen im Internet. Ganz klar, weil wenn du mit so einem Ding aufkommst, dann gibt es natürlich immer erst mal Gegenrede, bevor man sich irgendetwas angeschaut hat. Und ich kann das nur allen empfehlen, die in irgendeiner Form mit Computern spielen und unterwegs sind, sich das mal ein bisschen näher anzuschauen. Ja, so, was haben wir noch auf unserer Liste? Minecraft, machen wir mal alles hier schön zu.
Jumbo Jumbo.
Ach so, da waren wir ja schon. Ah ja, genau, wir müssen mal über Podcast-Apps reden. Es gab diese Woche mindestens zwei neue Podcast-Apps für die iOS-Plattform. Das eine kam etwas überraschend, das andere nicht, weil schon seit einem halben Jahr klar ist, was es ist. Die Rede ist natürlich von Overcast, von Marco Amendt, der relativ bekannt ist, weil er einerseits ein sehr elaborierter Podcaster geworden ist und als Programmierer von Instapaper natürlich auch zu einigen Rum gekommen ist. Früher war er bei Tumblr und hat jungs auch von diesem Tumblr-Verkauf, glaube ich, ganz ordentlich profitiert, sodass jetzt Geld auf einmal nicht mehr so sehr das Problem ist. Und jetzt kann er sich irgendwie Projekten widmen, die er einfach gerne machen möchte.
Ja, keine schlechte Idee.
Es gibt einen, habe ich glaube ich schon mal erwähnt, einen schönen Vortrag von ihm über wie er arbeitet auf der letztes Jahr auf der XOXO-Konferenz. Den sollte man auch nochmal kurz hervor kramen. Der ist, das ist glaube ich das hier.
Ja, genau, das ist glaube ich der Vortrag.
Warte mal, ich will mal ganz sicher sein. Ja, ich bin mir glaube ich relativ sicher. Genau, und da hat er auch das erste Mal angekündigt, da hat er das erste Mal angekündigt, dass er in einer Podcast-App arbeitet und hat wirklich eine sehr interessante Analyse auch dieser Dynamik der Podcast-Landschaft. Also eine, die ich nur vollständig teilen kann. Insofern war ich auch sehr gespannt, wie diese Software so ist. Ich weiß nicht, hat das von euch jemand runtergeladen?
Overcast? Ich glaube.
Dennis wahrscheinlich eh nicht. Du glaubst es nur, Huggle weiß das nicht.
Warte mal, lass mich mal kurz gucken. Doch, ich glaube, ich hab das runtergeladen und musste dann feststellen, dass irgendwie nach zwei oder drei Versuchen, irgendwelche Podcasts zu abonnieren und dieses Teil immer wieder gescheitert ist, habe ich es dann wieder sein lassen. Also es war irgendwie nur so.
Achso, klar. Ja, also insbesondere in Deutschland und insbesondere die Meta-Ebene Podcasts waren irgendwie problematisch.
Ja, aber auch so die anderen Sachen, so diese, was so das öffentliche Fernsehen so von sich gibt und solche Sachen, war, also ich bin nicht erfolgreich gewesen. Ich hab's allerdings jetzt auch nicht wirklich mit viele Laden probiert. Das Einzige, was irgendwie ging, war Bits und so. Aber ansonsten war ich nicht so erfolgreich.
Ja, ich muss jetzt auch gleich nochmal gucken, was eigentlich kommt. Wenn man hier Meta-Ebene hat, hat sich aber schon deutlich gebessert hier. Also da ist jetzt schon doch einiges dabei, aber vollständig ist es immer noch nicht.
Na ja, er hatte irgendwie ja geschrieben, dass er das jetzt irgendwie gefixt hat und dass man Meta-Ebene jetzt gucken könnte. Hattest du das nicht irgendwie retweeted?
Jaja, er hatte irgendwie einen Fehler mit MimeType, Climbim mit M4A. Keine Ahnung, was er da falsch gemacht hat. Auf jeden Fall war das der Grund, warum die MPEG-4-Feeds nicht gingen. Die MP3-Feeds waren kein Problem. Er hat sich offensichtlich dafür entschieden, ein komplett eigenes Podcast-Verzeichnis aufzubauen, ohne auf iTunes zurückzugreifen. Das finde ich ganz schön gewagt, weil er im Prinzip jeden User erst mal zwingt, die Feed-URL da rein zu tun, bevor der Podcast überhaupt erst mal sichtbar ist. Ich weiß auch nicht genau, wie er das gebootstrapped hat, ob er das eigentlich irgendwie nennenswert gebootstrapped hat.
Aber macht Martin das nicht auch?
Was?
Ein eigenes Podcast-Verzeichnis?
Ja, aber wenn du suchst, suchst du in iTunes. Und alles, was quasi einmal dort gefunden wurde, das landet dann als Feed im Instacast-Directorie und wird da eben dann für das eigene Syncing verwendet. Also man nutzt zum Beispiel, also man nutzt schon mal einfach iTunes als Füllhorn. Und ehrlich gesagt hätte ich das auch erwartet, dass er das hier auch für Overcast macht, hat er aber nicht. Ja, ich finde das Ding jetzt nicht sonderlich hübsch und ich finde es auch nicht besonders pfiffig, was so die Bedienungen betrifft. Das ist für meinen Geschmack eher so okay. Kann man machen so, aber ja, es ist nicht wirklich schlecht. Es haut mich aber auch nicht total vom Hocker. Alles was so Font und Spacing und so weiter betrifft, finde ich es ein bisschen problematisch. Finde ich irgendwie nicht so gelungen. Ich habe jetzt noch nicht so super viel damit gearbeitet. Im Wesentlichen funktioniert es. Man kann die Software auch kostenlos runterladen. Dann hat man aber keinen 3G-Download, keinen Cellular-Download. Und du kannst auch diese Special-Playback-Funktionen nicht länger benutzen als eine bestimmte Zeit. Die Funktionen sind, dass du so einen Boost-Modus zuschalten kannst. Also er hat quasi so eine Kompressor-Equalizer-Kombo gebaut, die halt im Prinzip das Sprachsignal lauter macht. Wenn du also einen leisen Podcast hast, der eben nicht von Auffonik überarbeitet worden ist, dann macht er das quasi in Realtime. Und hat da eben mit Core Audio sich da die entsprechenden Plugins oder Audio-Units zusammengeklickt und wirft die Daten an. Wie adaptiv das Ganze ist, weiß ich nicht, wahrscheinlich nicht sonderlich, weil das würde ja dann wirklich noch mal enorm viel Prozessing-Power abschießen. So oder so hat er sich aber wohl sehr intensiv mit Core Audio auseinandergesetzt, weil er einen eigenen Player gebaut hat, der eine zweite ganz interessante Funktion macht. Und zwar nennt er die Smart...
Smart...
Ja, eben wusste ich es noch. Smart Speed, genau, Smart Speed nennt er das.
Was ist denn das Video, was hier zwischendurch läuft?
Das war gerade mein Telefon, was hier Dinge ausgegeben hat. Smart Speed. Und Smart Speed ist quasi die Beschleunigung des Abspielens durch das Weglassen langer Pausen oder beziehungsweise das Verkürzen existierender Pausen. Sprich, er scannt, er macht so ein Lookahead auf dem Audio und hat halt irgendwo einen Threshold, in dem er eben etwas als Silence versteht und schneidet diese Silence zusammen. Das ist im Übrigen, wie zu vermuten, ein Ergebnis einer Schneidetechnik, die er auch verwendet hat, was ich ganz pfiffig fand, um die Podcast-Aufnahmen für diesen ATP-Podcast zu bearbeiten. ATP ist ja dieser Advanced-Tech-Podcast mit Syracusa, Casey, Liz und ihm. Das machen die mit Skype und bringen dann ihre Aufnahmen zusammen. Wenn du drei Skype-Teilnehmer hast, dann kann es eben schon mal sein, dass du diese Clock-Deviation extrem hast. Das heißt, dass so eine Aufnahme...
Nicht nur bei dreien, schon bei zweien, oder?
Ja, richtig, aber dann wird es halt immer immer konfus. Er hat sich dann eine Software geschrieben, die quasi das Timing der einzelnen Spuren gegeneinander anpasst, aber eben nicht, indem er so eine Audioverzerrung macht, also nicht, indem er da so eine Geschwindigkeit reinrechnet, sondern indem er sich halt einfach die Sprechpausen nimmt und die entsprechend verlängert oder verringert. Und das war dann, vermute ich jetzt mal, da habe ich ihn so nicht direkt sagen hören, Accidental Tech Podcast, heißt der Podcast natürlich nicht, etwa ein Tech Podcast, Entschuldigung. Naja, und das hat er jetzt irgendwie in diese Podcast abreingebracht. Und das finde ich an sich schon mal einen ganz interessanten Value. Also er ist jetzt überhaupt der Erste, der wirklich mehr als nur das reine Abspielen macht, sondern das irgendwie komplett in die eigene Hand nimmt. Das hat natürlich dann diesen Nebeneffekt, dass eben so ein Streaming-Betrieb gar nicht möglich ist, zumindest nicht out of the box mit den Bordmitteln. Das müsste er dann sozusagen auch nochmal von Hand machen. Sicherlich vorstellbar, aber ist eben derzeit noch nicht drin.
Und die Meter eben eine Podcast und dann plötzlich nur noch halb so lang.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich habe keine rechte Vorstellung davon, wie groß diese Verkürzung wirklich ist. Er zeigt das nicht an und ich weiß nicht. Manches finde ich dann so ein bisschen affig, wenn er halt den Podcast abspielt, dann hast du ja auch noch so Audio-Pegel-Anzeige, die irgendwie so mitten reingeklatscht ist. Das ist ein bisschen merkwürdig. Die Farben sind alle ein bisschen merkwürdig. Also im Großen und Ganzen noch keine nennenswerte Konkurrenz für so ausgewachsene Teile wie InstaCast, weil die einfach sehr viel mehr abdecken. Aber ja, kann man schon mal ausprobieren, insbesondere solange man noch nicht das 5-Euro-Upgrade bezahlt hat, um dann eben diese Special Features zu bekommen. Was allerdings, wenn ich das richtig sehe, jetzt bin ich mir gerade wieder nicht so sicher, hier hat er irgendwie kein richtiges Audios-Crawling drin, ne. Also diese Frequenzanzeige ist wirklich ganz furchtbar. Sie liegt hier so, schaut euch das mal an. Siehst du das Gehopse da? So ein blass-oranger Overlay über den Show Notes oder was auch immer da gerade dann angezeigt wird. Das hüpft dann halt so ein bisschen hin und ich finde das komplex.
Ja, so eine Frequenzanzeige ist immer ein bisschen prollig, finde ich. Also wenn man jetzt nicht wirklich eine technische Anwendung dafür hat, ist das auch total sinnlos.
Ja, also ich muss sagen, grundsätzlich habe ich gar nichts dagegen, wenn mir mal visualisiert wird, dass da auch Audio ist. Einfach, wenn man so das Gefühl hat, man hört nichts und weiß jetzt nicht...
Das kann man auch mit drei Lämpchen machen.
Ja eben, das kann man auch mit drei Lämpchen machen. Da hat dann auch noch so ein Slide-to-Scroll-Ding drin, wie das schon Castro auch hat. Da ist mir immer ein bisschen unklar, wo es eigentlich jetzt aktiv ist, weil hier ist es gerade irgendwie nicht aktiv und dann hier hat er aber so ein View und wenn man da falsch scrollt, dann... also ich weiß nicht, begeistert bin ich nicht. Von daher ist das jetzt auch irgendwie keine Empfehlung. Viel interessanter fand ich dann eigentlich ein anderes Podcast-Tool, was auch diese Woche erst rausgekommen ist, was nämlich wirklich mal was Neues gemacht hat. Wir können ja hier auch mal den zweiten Bildschirm anmachen, dann kann ich euch das mal zeigen, während ich das hier ausprobiere. Wozu haben wir denn hier diese ganzen Magie?
Source HDMI 2 No Signal.
Wir sehen ein iPhone.
Genau, ihr seht ein iPhone.
Also den Bildschirm von einem iPhone. Tim scrollt durch die Apps.
Very Dramatic Music.
Ach, Instrumente hab ich vergessen.
Genau, also MoCast würde ich jetzt auch nicht als komplett ausgereift bezeichnen.
Würdest du irgendeine Podcast ab als total ausgereift bezeichnen?
Nämlich?
Das kam so aus der Pistole geschossen.
Ja, ausgereift genug. Ja, gibt's eigentlich viele Beispiele. Also soll ich die jetzt wirklich alle nennen? Mir geht's jetzt erst mal hier um die Podcast-Line. Also erst mal hier abonnieren und so weiter war alles überhaupt gar kein Problem. Ich vermute mal, die gehen über das Attunusverzeichnis, auch wenn das hier nicht so richtig genannt wird. Ich hab's noch nicht so hundertprozentig verstanden, aber sie sind irgendwie sehr wuchtig. Also zum Beispiel benutzen sie diese merkwürdige IOS 7 Funktionen, mit denen man so aus dem Cover des Podcasts dann automatisch so eine Hintergrundfarbe oder so ein Hintergrundschleier da macht, womit du dann wieder diese merkwürdigen fleckigen, dreckigen Highscroll-Sachen hast. Also das verstehe ich einfach nicht. Ihr seht das hier, so CRE und irgendwie so die Tatsache, dass da dieser Zug drin ist, führt jetzt zu so einem komischen, unförmigen schwarzen Klecks hier in der Mitte, während man alles durchscrollt. Das verstehe ich nicht. Das sieht irgendwie für mich einfach nicht schön aus. Grundsätzlich finde ich aber die Idee, so eine Basisfarbe oder so eine Primärfarbe zu identifizieren und die dann automatisch als Background Highlighting für diese Episoden dieses Podcasts ganz gut. Weil du eben auf den ersten Blick das irgendwie siehst. Also bei den Podcast-Apps, die jetzt wirklich alles so in diesem iOS 7 weiß, ja, dünner Text und weiß und weiß und dünner Text so durchscrollen, da muss ich halt immer zehnmal hinschauen, bis ich irgendwas finde. Und ich frage mich, gut, manchmal ist halt das Icon dabei, das hilft dann schon mal. Aber das hier gleich so farblich zu machen, ist an sich ein ganz guter Ansatz. Und was ich besonders cool finde, hier tut er sich mit meinen Show Notes irgendwie noch schwer, habe ich so den Eindruck, ist, dass wenn ich jetzt so eine Episode auswähle, dass ich jetzt von hier steuern kann, klar, das Ding irgendwie runterzuladen, das will man ja auch, aber er hat halt auch ein Cueing. Und das ist so eine Funktion, auf die habe ich ehrlich gesagt schon länger gewartet. Ich hatte sie zwar nicht so richtig hinter diesem Namen im Kopf, aber ich will eigentlich an so einem Podcast-Client immer das Angebot sehen, schnell, was ist neu, was ist da. Also ich will schnell umherschalten zwischen, was ist jetzt schon runtergeladen, weil es gibt einfach Situationen, in denen will ich nur auf das zurückgreifen, was schon runtergeladen ist, weil in dem Moment für mich runterladen keine Option ist, weil zu teuer, zu langsam oder keine Ahnung, ich steige gleich irgendwo ein, wo es kein Let's gibt und ab jetzt ist Laden für mich kein Thema. Wenn ich irgendwo so einen schnellen Switch habe, der mir einfach nur noch alles anzeigt, was schon runtergeladen ist, das fände ich mal ganz toll. Meiner Erinnerung nach war das in der ersten Version von Instacast drin und flog dann irgendwie relativ früh wieder raus. Sehr schade. Die zweite Sache, die jetzt hier bei diesem MoCast mit dabei ist, ist dieses Cueing. Dass man aus dem Angebot der angezeigten Episoden und Podcasts sich einfach eine Cue macht. Also das will ich hören. Eine Playlist vielleicht sogar. Ja, Playlist heißt es halt oft nur, dass dieses Hinzufügen zu Playlisten, das ist irgendwie für meinen Geschmack bisher überall viel zu statisch. Ich gucke hier auf diesen Podcast, hier ist so ein Cue-Button, ich drücke da drauf, zack, bumm, ist es irgendwie in der Cue. Und ich lege mir eine Playlist an, die nenne ich Tims Lieblingsepisoden und da tue ich die dann rein oder so. Oder ich tue irgendwelche Podcasts rein. Ich will einfach nur sagen, das will ich hören, das will ich hören, das will ich hören, das will ich hören. Nicht wann ich das hören will und in welcher Reihenfolge ich das hören will, sondern es landet einfach in dieser Cue.
Also so ein bisschen wie bei iTunes, die als nächstes zu spielen Liste.
Genau, so ein bisschen.
Lass mal sehen, das ist jetzt deine Cuete Liste.
Ja genau, ich hab hier noch so ein bisschen wenig Podcasts drin, aber ich kann hier nochmal was mit reinnehmen. Zack, hier haben wir noch was, da, zack, Cue und jetzt so. Und dann sieht man das halt auch in dieser Liste gleich mit den entsprechenden Hintergrundfarben und das ist irgendwie an sich ganz fancy.
Kannst du das umsortieren?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage und das kann man hier irgendwie nicht, hab ich so den Eindruck, also ich wüsse jetzt nicht wie. Und das ist natürlich Quatsch. Also man muss in dieser Liste dann die Reihenfolge wirklich so regeln können, dass man einfach nur sagt, okay, jetzt, next. Also auch dieses Mo-Cast ist irgendwie komisch, aber auch die machen ganz interessante Sachen hier unten mit so einer Slider-Geste auf dem Player. Ja, also das kam ja mit Castro, so dieses, ich wische langsam mit dem Finger rüber und definiere damit so einen Scroll-Amount. Hier ist es sogar so, dass man eben so ein relatives Scrolling damit machen kann und während ich so nach links oder rechts wische, zeigt er mir dann an, wie viel Zeit ich jetzt übersprungen hätte in die eine oder in die andere Richtung. Also jetzt halte ich das hier gerade und er sagt mir, ok, du würdest landen bei drei Minuten irgendwas und von dem Punkt, von dem du aus gerade losgehst, bist du halt 1.21 zurückgegangen. Also man kann relativ schnell und effizient in so einem Podcast vor- und zurückmarschieren und er zeigt einem halt irgendwie auch so die Dauer an. Ich würde jetzt noch nicht sagen, dass das schon total gelungen ist und das Beste was gibt, aber es funktioniert so ein bisschen. Ja, also das wären so ein bisschen meine Tipps und ich finde es irgendwie an sich ganz gut, dass da jetzt einfach was passiert. Also dass es einfach so viele neue Podcast-Apps gibt und teilweise finde ich es auch nicht so gut. Also gut finde ich, dass so viele Leute bereit sind, da was zu schreiben. Nicht so gut finde ich, dass man jetzt unter Umständen noch mehr Contender hat, die man alle versuchen muss, in irgendein Boot zu kriegen, um zum Beispiel mal ein paar ordentliche Standards zu implementieren. Wär ja auch mal was, ne? Ich wette, es gibt auch noch ein paar andere. Ich weiß auch noch von einem anderen Podcast-Client, der demnächst kommen wird aus Deutschland. Den darf ich aber noch nicht verraten. Da kommt also auch noch mal was.
Hast du da gerade?
Jaja, hab ich schon. Und gibt auch noch immer die anderen, über die wir schon alle gesprochen haben. Einer wäre vielleicht noch der Erwähnung wert. Den finde ich zwar jetzt als Podcast-Player auch nur so, naja, so mittelprächtig. Der ist, sagen wir mal, eher einfach und straightforward. Heißt, kann ich euch auch noch mal kurz zeigen hier, damit ihr das zumindest mal gesehen habt, wenn ich davon rede. Heißt Short Orange und naja, es hat so, sagen wir mal, das Minimum an Funktionalität. Also man kann hier wieder ein Verzeichnis suchen und gegebenenfalls auch finden. Kann jetzt hier Freak Show finden, Freak Show abonnieren, mir anschauen, was in Freak Show drin ist und Freak Show Content herunterladen. Alles ganz toll. Warum erwähne ich denn diesen Player, wenn er an sich eigentlich nicht so viel hat? Das ist halt mal einer der wenigen Player, der wiederum noch eine richtige Webseite dahinter hat. Die einerseits mir ermöglicht, mit demselben Account mich da einzuloggen. Das ist dann nämlich shortorange.com. Siehst du, ich logg mich hier in diese Seite ein und genau der Podcast, den ich jetzt gerade auf dem iPhone mit abonniert habe, taucht jetzt hier auch auf. Ich kann hier auch genau so die Sendung abspielen. Es ist quasi nicht nur ein iOS-Player, sondern das gibt es auch noch als Android und das gibt es eben auch als Webseite. Das heißt, man kann seine Spielpositionen und was man eben schon gehört hat und was nicht und was man überhaupt abonniert hat eben einfach komplett in der Cloud auch mit verwalten und da eben auch spielen. Also während du ja bei Instacast Cloud derzeit das Syncing hast und so zumindest noch diese Autoflatter-Funktionen gibt es da zumindest noch keinen Player und keine Verwaltung der Subscriptions. Bei Short Orange ist das alles mit drin. Insofern sind die eigentlich auch am meisten vorangeschritten. Es gibt auch noch ein zweites webbasiertes Podcast-Portal, was aber, glaube ich, noch keine... Wir haben eine Android-App, genau. Da gibt es aber noch nichts unter iOS, soll aber wohl auch irgendwie kommen. Ist so von der Webseite her slightly more improved, das heißt player.fm. Und da kann man dann halt auch sich einen Account machen und kann seine eigenen Kanäle da verwalten.
Und gibt es da auch den wichtigsten Podcast der Welt?
Ja, taucht jetzt hier komischerweise nicht als Podcast, sondern als Episode auf. Also player.fm gibt mir mehr so das Gefühl, mehr so ein bisschen mehr was von Soundcloud her, so von der Haptik.
Aber er zeigt jetzt schon auch die anderen, älteren Podcasts von uns an.
Jaja, tut er.
Also er zeigt dann den neuesten in der Übersicht und dann, wenn du drauf gehst, dann kommen auch ältere.
Ja, man kann ja auch subscriben. Also das funktioniert schon auch wie ein richtiger Podcast-Player. Similar to Freak Show ist Freak Show. Wird hier noch Not Safe For Work angezeigt. Ich weiß bloß gerade nicht, wo ich irgendwie... Ah, hier, Channels nennt sich das dann hier.
Meine Channels. Und das heißt dann Tim Pritlav FM.
Also das ist alles mehr so auf diesem Soundcloud oder Last FM Gedanken im Design, was ich so recht nicht verstehe.
Ja, und sehen. Mal gucken.
Ich hoffe, dass wir ja auch mal mit dem Portlar-Fabplayer soweit fertig sind, dass man für solche Portale das Ding auch mal anbieten kann. Also tut sich was, ne? Und ja, bin gespannt.
Hast dich gerade ein bisschen mit Eis bematzt.
Wirklich, so bin ich.
Und jetzt noch breit geschmiert.
Ja, und die wollen wir dann auch, diese ganzen webbasierten Sachen wollen wir dann demnächst auch mit unserem Subscribe-Button unterstützen. Das ist so ein bisschen der Plan. Und die antworten wir wenigstens, wenn man ihnen eine Mail schreibt. Während diese ganzen Podcast-Client-Developer, die sind irgendwie alle, ich weiß auch nicht, was mit denen ist. Also die sind nicht so ansprechbar.
Wahrscheinlich kommen die alle aus ihren Löchern, wenn du erstmal die ersten Versionen draußen hast von den Button. Und dann sehen sie, dass sie da nicht aufgeführt werden.
Ups, das Fenster wollte ich jetzt nicht zumachen. So, jetzt wollte uns ja David noch zwingen über Ingress zu reden.
Ich hab so eine Befürchtung.
Oder?
Na, ich hab mir das nie angeguckt. Ich hab einmal diesen Vorgänger gespielt, von denen die wohl eine Menge geklaut haben.
Ich hab das auch noch nie gespielt, keine Ahnung, nie angeschaut.
Ja, du läufst durch die Straßen und dann blubberst die ganze Zeit blau oder grün irgendwo.
Ja, und dann muss er da irgendwie...
Sehe ich das richtig? Das ist von Google? Haben die da irgendwie die Bude aufgekauft oder sind die da selber drauf gekommen?
Nee, da gab es vorher schon so ein Spiel, da gab es so ein oranges und ein grünes Team. Und da hat sich das schon mal erzählt, wo ich immer hier zum Nordbahnhof gefahren bin, genau um da irgendwie die Gegend klar zu machen. Und das Brandenburger Tor gehörte mir eine Weile lang immer mal wieder. Aber das konnte man halt auch nicht halten auf Dauer. Aber so richtig spaßig war es nach einer Weile nicht. Also irgendwie, ich weiß ja auch nicht.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht.
Also ich als Spieler-Agnostiker bin da eh nicht die richtige Abteilung.
Aber wohl die USB-Booster wurden für dieses Spiel erfunden, wenn ich das so richtig verstehe.
USB-Booster?
Batterie.
So Batteriebooster.
Ach so, weil das so eine Batterie ist.
Ja, weil die Leute jetzt nicht auf ihr Fahrrad schwingen oder was auch immer. Und das ganze Zeit läuft halt diese App und die frisst ja auch nicht gerade wenig, glaube ich, durch die Ressourcen, die die da so benutzen. Und deswegen ist immer relativ schnell die Batterie leergezogen. Deswegen musste immer so ein dicker Akku-Pack noch mit ran. Aber ich habe auch noch nie ein Live so spielen gesehen. Also in meiner Umgebung sind nicht so Spieler davon am Start.
Na, jetzt das C-Base ist voll davon.
Ja, die C-Base, die war schon immer so ein bisschen anders drauf, ne?
Ja, es hat sich nur in dieser anderen Szene halt wirklich so verbreitet und ich weiß nicht, also klar, dann gewinnt man den Brunnen und dann kommen die anderen und holen die sich wieder zurück.
Ach so, genau, was man gehört hat, da gibt es ja irgendwie Level oder so, bis zum Level 9 oder welcher Level war es und auch, dass viele dann, wenn die beim letzten Level angekommen sind, dann gab es irgendwie nicht mehr so richtig Motivation, irgendwie weiter zu machen, weil ja, was machst du, wenn du den höchsten Level hast? Also es kann sein, dass es cool ist, aber Level 18 schreiben die im Chat gerade, aber ja.
Wir sind begeistert. Wir sind begeistert, schön, dass es dann auch geklappt hat. Schampagner, Herr Kapellmeister, jetzt bitte die nationalen Hymne, ne?
Problem bei Ingress ist auch, du kommst halt hoch und dann wirst du gefragt, ob du halt blau oder grün sein willst.
Wer will denn bei Team Green spielen?
Weißt du, hier ist nicht der ganze Club irgendwie auf grün?
Nee, Team Green ist hier, die spielen am Straßenrand und ziehen nicht rein.
Nee, da ist blau.
Ja, inzwischen.
Die wollen uns austricksen. Klassisch heißen die Team Green.
Ja, aber so sagt er mir schon so, this is final.
Ja, und jetzt ist auf einem anderen Gerät nochmal das andere. Machen ja schon auch viele. Ist ja verboten.
Ist ja auf dem Account, auf dem Google-Account.
Hier, dann machst du halt noch einen Google-Account. Merken die doch nicht. Doch, merken die.
Das ist mir auch ehrlich gesagt ziemlich egal. Ich, ja, also jetzt bin ich wahrscheinlich einfach wieder der totale Ignorant und ignoriere alles, was es doch für ein Zauber ist, dass man dann am ganzen Tag mit dem Fahrrad durch die Gegend fährt und sich irgendwie Orte anschaut, die man sonst nie mit dem Arsch angeguckt hätte. Solche Effekte gibt es ja durchaus. Das finde ich auch alles ganz toll.
Ich wollte eigentlich auch nicht zum Nordbahnhof.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, da geht es mir wieder so wie mit vielen anderen, nicht mit allen, aber mit vielen anderen Spielen so dieses...
Warum?
Also ich weiß einfach gar nicht, warum mich das jetzt so begeistern soll, weil da kommt am Ende einfach nüscht bei raus. Also dir gehört was oder das gehört dir dann wieder nicht?
Ja, aber das ist ja nun bei vielen Spielen so, dass nüscht bei rauskommt.
Deswegen finde ich das ja auch so lame. Also es ist halt das, was... weiß ich nicht, mich... zeigt das einfach nicht. Ich kriege da keinen Kick draus.
Mich kickt das einfach alles.
Aber Kalender kickt mich ja auch nicht. Klar. Kalender ist doch dein Ding oder andere Sachen, die du machst. Also manche Sachen, die macht man halt einfach.
Kalender nervt mich, wenn er scheiße ist. Aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass mir da gleich einer bei abgeht.
Er kickt dich nicht, wenn er gut ist.
Ich finde, sowas muss man halt einfach mal hinkriegen und dann ist gut.
So, also Tower 2 rufe ich auf die Agenda jetzt.
Nee, es ist ein Git-Client.
In Version 2.0 hatten wir hier auch in Version 1 schon vorgestellt mal.
Und jetzt gibt es Tower 2.
Und ich finde das ja ein recht gelungenes Update. Ich habe den halt immer so benutzt. Eigentlich also die destruktiven Operationen, die habe ich immer auf der Command Line gemacht. Aber so das Commit-Log-Brausen und so Stagen von Commits und so, das habe ich schon gerne mit dem Tower gemacht. Und jetzt haben sie das Interface mal so ein bisschen aufgeräumt, finde ich ganz gut.
Also ich habe das Einser nie benutzt und habe mir jetzt das Zweier angeguckt und finde es extrem unübersichtlich. Also sowohl dieses Committen als auch diesen View da von den Branches, das ist irgendwie nicht so mein Ding.
Ich benutze das tatsächlich schon seit Längerem. Und gerade so dieses Line-by-Stagen, was du auf der Command Line einfach nicht ordentlich hinbekommst.
Ich benutze ja immer dieses GitX-Log.
Aber ich finde, hier so drüber scrollen und hier einfach sagen, die Zeile rein, die Zeile raus. Ich finde das hier geiler.
Also wie gesagt, ich arbeite immer mit GitX aus dem Laulon-Fork.
Das ist mir zu braun mittlerweile.
Könnte ja mal ein bisschen deutlicher werden.
Hier geht es gerade um Git-Clients.
Ja, das habe ich soweit schon verstanden.
Also, Gordi benutzt einen Client, der von irgendeinem Typen mal vor Äonen von Jahren programmiert wurde und seitdem 20 Milliarden mal geforkt wurde. Und er benutzt einen dieser Forks, der immer noch das Kadaver, das Tod, das Luder irgendwie immer noch ein Stück weiter ist.
Aber ich finde, er ist gegen diesen Git Tower 2 eigentlich immer noch ganz gut im Rennen. Weil ich finde diesen Git Tower so unglaublich unübersichtlich. Und was ich echt schlimm finde, ist, du kannst nicht auf einen bestimmten Commit rebasen. Also zumindest habe ich es nicht hingekriegt auf Anhieb, habe denen eine Mail geschrieben, habe noch nichts zurückgehört.
Wie gesagt, die krassen Operationen, die mache ich auf der Command Line. Aber ich finde das so einen schönen Browser einfach. Und Stager, dafür benutze ich den.
Ich finde ihn ein bisschen unübersichtlich, aber naja, ist vielleicht noch mein Ding. Dafür habe ich mir das Git-Up-Jam installiert. Das ist ganz interessant, da sagt man einmal Git-Up und er holt einfach alles, was man irgendwie...
Jemals ausgecheckt hat?
Ja, in einem Repository, was man jemals als Branch von Remote nach Local geholt hat. Fetched er und rebased das, wenn nötig, auf die neueste Version. Und dann macht man einfach einmal Git-Up und dann ist irgendwie alles wieder schick.
Was wir in Tower 2 eingebaut haben, ist ein schönes Merch-Tool auch. Also ich würde sagen, es gibt eine 30 Tage Trial, man kann sich das Tower 2 ruhig mal angucken.
Ja, ich habe das ja heute auch runtergeladen und habe da gleich angefangen mit Trialen, aber irgendwie bin ich da nicht auf Anhieb warm geworden mit. Vor allen Dingen, weil ich das so unübersichtlich finde, ist, wenn du links in der Liste einen Branch anklickst, dann blendet er irgendwie alle anderen Branches aus. Und wenn du aber dann in der Liste oben, da steht dann irgendwie History, da gibt es noch so einen Punkt History, wenn du da draufklickst, kriegst du wieder die gesamte History, aber dann kannst du nicht zu dem Branch-Head von irgendeinem Branch hinscrollen.
Kannst aber hier halt Multiple Branches selecten und die dann sozusagen sich unifiziert anzeigen lassen.
Ja, irgendwie, na, das hat mich einfach nicht überzeugt. Ich finde den einfach unübersichtlich und fertig.
Aber man sieht ja auch die Files irgendwie selber nicht drin, kann das sein?
Doch, es gibt den Tree, hier kann man da rechts klicken und dann siehst du auch den File Tree.
Ja, den File, der ist finde ich jetzt nicht so spannend, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich benutze eigentlich immer Xcode zum Committen und so weiter und benutze dann Command Line zum Pushen, Pullen und den ganzen Rest.
Aber manchmal willst du halt, ja genau, aber manchmal willst du halt hier irgendwie das File anbrausen und sagen hier Show File History oder Blame oder...
Aber ehrlich gesagt, Blame benutze ich nur noch in Xcode, weil das ist schon sehr geil. Dass du es einfach anmachst und setzt...
Wer in Xcode codet, kann das machen.
Ja, weil du machst es an und dann zeigt er halt zu jeder Zeile den Blame an. Und du kannst halt auch direkt gucken, was war das eigentlich für ein Commit und so. Das macht Xcode eigentlich ganz anständig.
Da steht aber gar nicht mehr Blame, da steht da irgendwie was anderes. Von wem es halt war, aber nicht Blame.
Ja, die Funktion ist im Prinzip der Blame-View. Aber wie die jetzt den Blame-View nennen, ich glaube der wird gar nicht groß. Es ist halt dieser Button mit dem Typ drauf.
Da rechts oben war gerade zum Beispiel ein Tree.
Das sieht zumindest aufgeräumter aus als das andere, was ich benutze. Was benutze ich hier?
Wahrscheinlich Source Tree.
Genau.
Source Tree hasse ich ja aus tiefster Seele.
Das ist so komisch und unübersichtlich.
Es ist nicht komisch, es ist komplett unübersichtlich. Überall kannst du dann nochmal einen Splitscreen aufklappen. Und irgendwann ist es so wie dieses Spiel, wo man immer aus dem Spielfeld ein Stück abschneiden muss, aber sich nicht erwischen lassen darf. Von dem Teil, das enthält Quicks oder wie das hieß. Ich wollte nicht wieder auf Spiele kommen, aber...
Also ich finde das ist auf den ersten Blick nicht so total verwirrend, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, aber ich finde diese Skittix ist halt viel aufgeräumter.
Es kann aber auch nichts.
Ja, aber es kann genau das, was ich brauche. Es kann rebasen, es kann mergen. Es kann einen Pull, einen Push, einen Fetch und fertig. Und alles andere mache ich sowieso auf der Command-Seile.
Ist ja okay, aber der kann hier tatsächlich so ganz nette Sachen noch zwischenwählen.
Um nicht zu sagen, der hat es halt nicht hingekriegt. Ich wollte halt einen Branch auf einem bestimmten Commit rebasen und das ging einfach nicht. Und da habe ich halt wieder zugemacht, was soll das? Also wirklich, was soll das?
Aber z.B. ein Rebase sowas würde ich eher auf der Command Line machen als im Client. Ach so, macht das jeder anders.
Naja, ich fange das Rebase immer im Client an und wenn es irgendwie Probleme gibt, dann mache ich auf der Kommandezeile weiter.
Lass uns mal den Unterschied erklären zwischen einem Rebase...
Und einem Merge?
Ja, ist das das, was man miteinander vergleichen muss?
Unter anderem, also ein Rebase kann man für alles Mögliche verwenden.
Stell dir vor, du hast 20 Komits und wie soll man es genau erklären?
Wir erklären das mal so. Stell dir einen Baum vor, so einen richtigen Baum. Der ist also über Jahre gewachsen und ungefähr auf 2 Meter Höhe spaltet sich dieser Baum in zwei große Bäume auseinander. Und Merge ist, wenn du jetzt oben den Baum wieder zusammen bindest, sodass er wieder zu einem stamm wird. Und Rebase ist, wenn du einen der beiden Teile absägst und oben, wo der andere Ast zu Ende ist, ihn wieder dran spackst.
Der nimmt die Komets zurück.
Also sozusagen die beiden eigentlich mehr oder weniger parallel verlaufenden Entwicklungsstränge so macht, dass der eine nach dem anderen kommt und es aussieht, als wäre das so durchgehend geändert geworden.
Bei Rebase kriegen die auch alle einen neuen Hasch, weil die Komets werden nochmal gemacht. Das heißt, du kannst zehn Komets, den nimmst du weg, machst deinen eigenen von Hand irgendwas rein, änderst irgendwie einen Copyright oder was irgendwie wichtig ist, machst es und danach bastest du die anderen da wieder oben drauf. Dadurch kriegen die aber alle einen neuen Hasch. Das heißt, das ist eigentlich auch eine gefährliche Geschichte. Also wenn du was schon irgendwo hin gepusht hast, dann ist ein Rebase ein bisschen scheiße, weil die anderen haben jetzt schon andere Hasches als du machst.
Nicht immer nur, wenn du die History rewritest, aber der übliche Fall ist halt, du hast halt deinen Head oder deinen Master hier ausgecheckt, du werkelst da währenddessen comitten deine Kollegen 23.000 Sachen. Und jetzt könntest du halt ein Merge machen, oder du pullst erstmal die ganzen Changes von den Kollegen und dann kannst du sagen, hier bei Pull, mach mal ein Pull Rebase. Was er dann tut ist, er nimmt erstmal deinen Commit beiseite, holt sich die ganzen Changes, die auf dem Hauptrepo gemacht wurden, und packt dann deinen obendrauf auf die neuen Master. Dann hast du die Chance, die Konflikte noch alle zu lösen, die vielleicht in der Zwischenzeit entstanden sind, und dann pushst du halt so ein schön sequentielles...
Aber kann man nicht einfach die eigenen Sachen irgendwie weg, wenn es an die Station ist, wenn sie noch nicht committed sind?
Also Rebase, weil man will halt eigentlich in so einem Workflow, in so einem Team, will man halt nicht diese Merge-Commits haben.
Du musst einfach mal auch auf einen Repository, was du schon hast, musst du mal so ein Rebase machen auf irgendwie einen Hashtag, der 20 Commits zurückliegt. Und dann kommt so ein, also nicht mit einem Gute, sondern mit einer Command-Line, kommt so ein Wim, so 20 Zeilen mit deinen 20 Commits. Und dann steht auch da, mit welchen Kommandos du da was machen kannst. Zum Beispiel kannst du auch in dem einfach eine Zeile löschen, den ganzen Commit löschen und dann replayt der die sozusagen. Oder du kannst zwei Commits zusammenfügen oder auseinanderdröseln. Oder die Reihenfolge kannst du ändern und all sowas. Also ist schon ziemlich mächtig, so ein Rebase.
Ja, und man kann eben History Rewritten kannst du halt auch noch machen. Wenn du auf einem Branch bist und du willst den jetzt auf den Hauptbranche rebasen, kannst du die ganzen Commits sozusagen in ein zusammenfassen. Dann sieht das so aus, als hättest du aus den 200 Commits, das ist eigentlich ein Feature-Commit nur geworden. Und sagst jetzt so, hier Big Feature Edit. Und die auf dem Hauptbranche sehen gar nicht, dass du in deinem Development-Branch da 200.000 Commits gemacht hast, sondern die sehen nur den einen zusammengesquaschten. Aber ja.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich auch so, wenn, was weiß ich, irgendjemand macht einen Fix, aber er macht den Fix auf dem falschen Branch.
Nee, es gibt ja noch Cherry Picking. Es gibt noch Cherry Picking, da kannst du ein ganz einzelnes Commit, so wie es ist, irgendwo anders noch mal einfügen.
Genau, eine Scheibe aus dem Baum rauslegen und hier oben wieder...
oben wieder draufdenkeln. Ganz organisch.
Nicht raus sägen, sondern raus kopieren.
Ganz organisch. Also ich würde jetzt mal so sagen, für so ein... ich bin ja noch eigentlich ein totaler Git-Noob, so.
Ja, Git hat so eine schwierige Lernkurve.
Ja gut, ich hab mich auch bisher, sagen wir mal, noch nicht mit zu viel Details auseinandersetzen müssen, weil ich das doch weitgehend nur für Kleinigkeiten benutze. Aber ich finde, das macht jetzt... die Aufteilung hier von Tower 2 finde ich jetzt nicht so falsch. Also ich finde, das macht jetzt erstmal so...
Ja, vielleicht muss ich mich nur dran gewöhnen, aber...
Sinn und hilft mir jetzt mehr als...
Sieht auf jeden Fall schön aufgeräumt aus, finde ich.
Man kann ja diese Commit-Dinger da auch klein machen. Man muss die nicht in diesen riesen Flatschen mit... Mit Bild und so. Man kennt die Leute eh.
Ja, also die Files wäre hier so ein Columnbrowser vielleicht nochmal ganz gut. Anyway, Tower 2 ist... Ist das nicht sogar Deutschland? Das ist doch aus Deutschland hier.
Ja, aus Stuttgart.
Tatsächlich.
So, hab ich das auch in Erinnerung.
Kostet ein bisschen was.
novr.com Software GmbH Stuttgart.
Ritterstraße, Kreuzberg, ja?
Die haben auch eine Berliner Adresse.
Schau dir an, schau dir an.
59 Dollar ist auf jeden Fall nicht das billigste, aber... zahlt die Firma, wa?
Aber die werden halt auch nicht so viele Lizenzen verkaufen. Da müssen wir schon ein bisschen mehr nehmen.
Also... Wieso nicht? Das merkt echt ganz schön viele Developer.
Aber trotzdem, also für ein liebevoll gemachtes Tool, für eine kleine Audience ist das schon okay. Okay, also...
Denke ich auch, dass es jetzt nicht kann.
Das muss man sich halt überlegen. Ist es einem wert oder nicht? Aber über Preismeckern finde ich immer langweilig.
Es sollte ja nicht so ein Tool sein, wo man dreimal irgendwie ein Bild mit ändert und dann braucht man das nicht mehr. Sondern wenn du halt Programming machst oder Zeug und du brauchst ein Git und du meinst, du kommst mit dem Tool ja klar, dann sollte es einem auch das wert sein.
Ja klar, wenn du mit einem Tool täglich arbeitest, dann...
Södle, dann kommen wir mal hier wieder auf unsere Liste. Ich glaube, wir hatten da noch was von Roddy.
Muss ich noch was erzählen?
Du weißt, du wolltest irgendwas fragen.
Ach so, ich hatte da so einen Link gefunden. Vielleicht ist das auch nur irgendein Netztreibgut. Indexeos, irgendeine Suchmaschine, die irgendwelche Daten, persönlichen Daten, irgendwie findet oder Zugangsdaten oder keine Ahnung. Hätte ja sein können, dass einer von euch was gehört hat.
Kann man mit Bitcoin bezahlen?
Also ich weiß auch nicht mehr als dieser Link jetzt hier.
Das ist einfach eine Suchmaschine für schon mal geleakte User Databases oder wie?
Exciting!
Dein Tumbleweed macht aber komische Geräusche.
Oh Gott, ey. Du brauchst mal ein Ventilator für die Sommermonate, Timme. So ein Deckenventilator oder irgendwas, was hier so ein bisschen Brise macht, das ich zerfliese hier so langsam.
Ein Deckenventilator.
Also ganz langsam leisen.
Es gibt eigentlich keine langsam leisen.
Dann bauen wir uns einen Widerstand rein.
Die drehen so ganz langsam, deswegen sind die doch so. Die haben große Flügel und drehen ganz langsam.
Ja, aber...
Hast du Angst?
Ich hatte schon mal ein Deckenventilator und das war jetzt nicht so...
Das war vielleicht nicht das Top-of-the-Line-Modell.
Dann vielleicht, also wo ich schon ein bisschen mit geliebeugelt habe und das wäre besser, wären eigentlich diese coolen...
Deißenteile.
Da gab es das Bild, wo einer direkt durchguckt aus dem Monitor, ne?
Der wäre super, weil ihr wisst, was ich meine, ne?
Ja, alle wissen.
Airflow, Airblade sind die Teile zum Händetrocknen. Airmultiplier, so heißen sie.
Multiplier, wirklich?
Ja, ein bisschen doofe Namen.
Genau, hier Airmultiplier und das gibt es irgendwie in verschiedenen...
In der alten Firma hatten wir so einen Teil und die sind schon ganz gut, aber wenn sie richtig pusten sollen, dann machen sie auch ein wenig...
Ja, die haben halt irgendwie kaum bewegliche...
Na ja, innen drin hat der auch einen Lüfter, nur der ist ein bisschen versteckt und die Luft kommt dann woanders raus, aber hören wird man den wahrscheinlich auch so ein bisschen?
Ja, aber die sind leiser.
Die sind leiser, aber du hörst ihn und wenn du wirklich Wind behandelst...
Aber der wird jetzt in dem kleinen Raum jetzt nicht so viel bringen, oder?
Doch, da auch so eine Brise...
Die schieben echt richtig die Teile. Das glaubst du gar nicht, was die für einen Zug haben.
Also ich bin ein bisschen skeptisch, dass so der Marketing-Hype wieder hier...
Aber echt...
Also ob sie das Geld wert sind, dass man das für bezahlt...
Für das Geld kannst du hier die Decke mit Papstlüftern tapezieren.
Ja, hier dieser Tischlüfter, dieser Kleine, der wäre jetzt hier genau das Richtige.
Für schlappe 330 Euro.
Guck mal, 75% leiser. Hauptsache leiser.
Als du selber.
Also wir sind nicht 45% leiser.
Und 40% geringerer Stromverbrauch. Was will man mehr?
Wie gesagt, Tim, da kannst du dir jetzt nochmal bis zum nächsten Mal was überlegen.
Sonst bringen wir uns hier alle USB-Lüfter mit.
Ich hab jetzt schon den ganzen Tag im 5. im Dachgeschoss in saunaartigen Zuständen gesessen. Das kann ich hier beim Podcast nicht auch noch verkraften.
Bei Amazon kostet er nur noch 319.
Du kannst ihn ja gleich auf deine Liste packen. Hast du nicht so eine Amazon-Liste?
Genau, Schnäppchen. Sonst keine Wünsche. Das ist einfach nur für Huckel, schreib ich gleich dran. Ich hatte den schon ein paar Mal in der Hand, aber der Preis hat mich dann doch abgeschreckt.
Ich glaube, das macht Spaß, wenn man den auf die Tischtennisplatte stellt.
Ich kann natürlich für sechs oder sieben Sendungen dann hier mal das Essen streichen, dann habe ich die Kohle wieder raus. Oder?
Solange nicht das Bier streist.
Du hast hier nur noch eine Frage, wann iOS 8 kommt, Roddy.
Na ja, da hat jemand so eine Tabelle gemacht.
Wann es theoretisch dran wäre, ja.
Wann ist es, genau, wann es so dran wäre. Nee, da hat halt jemand irgendwie aus der Wikipedia die gesamten Erscheinungsdaten der Betas rausgezogen und hat die in so eine Grafik zusammengefügt. Und da kann man mal gucken. Was auffällt, ist, dass die Nuller-Versionen immer so ein bisschen länger gedauert haben. Really. Und wenn man jetzt so guckt, na ja, 90 Tage.
Schon immer 90, oder?
120 Tage, hier iOS 5, 120 Tage in Beta.
4.0 ging ein bisschen schneller.
4.0 ging schneller.
Aber sonst immer so die 90, oder?
Schon über 90 Tage.
Drei Monate, wann ging es los? So wie mit den 10, also vor sechs Wochen.
Und wir haben jetzt hier ungefähr 50 Tage, also es dauert noch mindestens einen Monat. Kann man jetzt mal so sagen.
Ja, so sechs Wochen.
Also ich glaube auch nicht, dass im August irgendwas erscheint.
Glaube ich auch nicht.
Klickt mal auf den Chat.
Telefone kommen im September und dann kommt iOS 8.
Klickt mal auf den Chat, ich habe jetzt das passende Bild noch mal rausgesucht dazu, zu diesem Quote.
Und im Oktober kommt dann.
Das ging halt rum bei Vuga, als die Peak-Temperatur im Dachgeschoss erreicht war irgendwie. Es lag ein Sauna in hier. Diese Memen-Leute, die sich alle ausdenken, wenn es langweilig ist. Oh Gott, ich fahre auseinander. Übrigens eine Sache noch, ganz kurz, aber wirklich Schlusswort jetzt hier. Du hast hier von Wikigames ja mal erzählt. Ich mache diesen Kurs, Hitchhiker's Guide to the Internet, wo sie zum Weltwissen als Semesteraufgabe beitragen sollen. Da gibt es ja immer die Sache, entweder in die Wikipedia was schreiben oder OpenStreetMap oder ein Tutorial oder How-To irgendwo bloggen. Und dann habe ich jetzt, weil du das erwähnt hast, für die, die ganz kreativlos sind, die müssen in die Top 10 oder so von der Highscore von Wikidata kommen. Da ist ja noch nicht so viel los. Haben sie auch geschafft. Tatsächlich sind es zwei Studenten, haben sich dann in zwei, drei Kategorien auf Platz 1 geschossen und haben da wie die Wilden irgendwie getaggt. So, das als Backreference. Jetzt bin ich fertig, fix.
Huckele ist durch. Denn jetzt sieht Adi noch ganz fit aus.
Ich erzähl dann nächstes Mal, wie Wacken war.
Ja, sieht nach einer kleinen Sommerpause aus. Wir werden vermutlich erst in fünf Wochen wieder den Senderbetrieb aufnehmen.
Du hast gerade noch vier gesagt.
Sechs sind es gleich, wenn du nochmal widersprichst.
Kriegen wir Urlaubsflatter?
Das wird sich zeigen. Also jetzt sind ja noch sieben Tage in diesem Monat. Kannst ja jetzt nochmal was Freundliches sagen, Dennis.
Ihr seid die Besten.
Da hast du ja jetzt voll Mühe gegeben, Alter.
Das war überzeugend, ich fand das schon irgendwie sehr überzeugend.
Wird der Dom mit seinem Fanboys-Podcast? Hören die dann auf? Oder machen die dann mit...
Die haben ja noch genug Mitarbeit, die sie da ans Mikrofon setzen können.
Das wirst du dann sehen, oder? Oder hören.
Den anderen haben sie nicht genommen?
Den Mapp?
Vielleicht wollte er auch gar nicht.
Also genommen, der hat es, glaube ich, gar nicht beworben. Der ist auch ganz zufrieden, wo er da ist. Keine Ahnung, steckt er jetzt nicht so drin?
Ich finde es schon ein ganz schönes Ding. Ich weiß nicht, wie er so drauf ist, aber wie die Podcast ein Fanboy sagt, ist er wahrscheinlich schon der kleine Traum, für Apple-Programmierer bei Apple anzufangen.
Jetzt kratscht die noch eine halbe Stunde auf die Sentimentalität.
Können wir die nochmal einladen, bevor er abhaut?
Ja.
Goodbye-Party.
Bestimmt. Das ist ja noch, was nehme ich, das ist richtig erinnere Sprache von September? Wenn du zuhörst, kannst du ja schon mal ein Ticket nach Berlin buchen.
Aber erst in 5 Wochen, weil...
Erst im September.
5 Wochen Zeit.
Vorher ist es hier eh zu heiß.
Gut, gut.
Bitte schauen.
Jetzt leiten wir hier mal das Ende ein. Muss auch mal ein bisschen softer kommen, oder? Und bis dahin wünsche ich euch noch einen schönen Sommer.
Hey, wir haben gerade mal kurz nach 11.
Wir haben noch früh angefangen.